peu
[Musique]
roseau france d'en bas mois bienvenue
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui vous évite de regarder un
mauvais film avec nous ce soir
noël mamère au coeur de la polémique
guillaume depardieu la ferme et screen
rebondi avec les enfants mesrine julie
delpy dieudonné persiste et signe r jean
luc mélenchon à l'insolite s l'ucla
monde ont des soucis avec cindy fred
bureau preston milla basile boli native
de côte d'ivoire est notre fameux blind
est consacré ce soir au dessus de tout
moment par avec brasier avait augmenté
vous avez été très nombreux à regarder
tout le monde entament la semaine
dernière merci pour les quelques-uns qui
n'auraient pas vu l'émission
voici le testeur ça s'appelle tout le
monde attendait et c'est préparer car
jean noël magnéto serge j'ai été
administrateur d'une banque juge pendant
10 ans ce qui est rare parce que c'est
qu'une bande juive abbassi c'est quoi
une bande juifs pour vous et bat une
banque ou les viandes de juifs français
milite pas d'accord parce qu'il ya des
gens parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont
d'origine israël dans une banque la
banque de genband juive mais quand ils
sont huit ans mais la banque d'émission
disent qu'ici par exemple il y avait 350
députés juifs à l'assemblée nationale
l'assemblée nationale sur une assemblée
juive nous ah bon il veut dire quoi
quand il quand ils ont ils travaillent
dans les organisations jeunesse à saisir
je pense que tous les téléspectatrices
et téléspectateurs et 0 6 papon était
collaborateur
je vous assure je ne défendrai pas moi
je vais vous dire une chose c'est que
vous avez mis la mémoire de votre
famille au service d'une bien mauvaise
cause je ne le pense pas tu n'en je le
ferai pas merci les verts de beaux fois
[Musique]
dibaba thème les 10 de marie laforêt
moyennement mais c'est pas nouveau je
veux dire j'aimais beaucoup marie
laforêt quand c'était une jeune et
superbe actrice mais est-ce que sur tf1
la météo est droite il ya quelqu'un qui
présentait les télévisions sur tf1 qui a
été mis au placard
et pourtant c'est une personnalité de
valeur cherchez vous demandez vous allez
voir patrice dreux pas stricte will et
surfer sur les enfants sont des acteurs
parce que bonjour aux gendarmes leur aux
cowboys au docteur je suis sûr que lui a
beaucoup joué au docteur est alors bon
temps j'aurais bien la poupée barbie
comme d'habitude
ouais alors les habitudes ont mauvaise
presse et moi je trouve que les
habitudes c'est ce qui est plus de
délicieux dans la vie prendre son bain
c'est une merveilleuse habitude toujours
les six par jour
oui et puis la bulle
j'ai l'habitude que que que mon mari
rentre à la maison tué la victime
s'attribuant cordes abeid et puis le
soir j'entends son souffle sur
l'oreiller j'ai l'habitude de faire ça
si bon mois écouter je suis quelqu'un de
très sage mais je trouve qu'il ya autant
de sensualité qui lie à d'individus et
donc que les gens préfèrent les femmes
ou les hommes où tous les deux et tout
ça n'est ce pas thierry et bien le bilan
c'est que j'ai l'impression d'avoir été
un peu trop bavarde un an soit 0
vous savez mais justement au 14e siècle
il y a si on disait du mal de double ou
bush
écoutez moi ce qui me fout la trouille
c'est que il attaque vraiment l'irak
comme apparemment il y en a envie mais
bon le temps qu'ils le trouvent sur la
carte je pense qu'on a eu du mal de
stevie thiviers moi je l'appelle et
wonder steevy mais parce que comme
stevie wonder
j'ai lu aucun livre sorti j'ai du mal de
joey starr alors joeystarr c'est vous
êtes fous ouais j'ai vu joey starr
tabassé une hôtesse de l'air je lui joey
starr tabassé un singe comme je me situe
à peu près entre les deux alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes comme salman
rushdie victime d'une fatwa
il ya une prime vous abattre est ce que
vous savez de combien et le montant de
la prime
cette place à mike intégré testé sa
soeur de la ce qui n'est pas beaucoup
d'argent
ceci dit pour quelques femmes du
bangladesh et dovi c'est énorme
le best of de la semaine dern
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant huit mois ma mère on dit
de moi ma mère pourquoi les chiens dans
la rue de monde dessus
dites moi ma mère rosine deux mois ouais
si nole même heure
oui
[Musique]
noël bonsoir dirait qu'on parle de la
politique dont tout le monde parle qui
vous oppose à gérard depardieu
[Musique]
samedi dernier avait lieu à bègles donc
un match de rugby bègles contre le stade
français
la veille à la fin d'un point de presse
où vous aviez parlé d'autre chose
vous avez déclaré demain je n'irai pas
au match
vous avez ajouté quand monsieur
bouteflika le président algérien est
venu à l'assemblée nationale j'ai quitté
l'hémicycle
demain monsieur khalil fall le sponsor
du club devrait être là et moi noël
mamère je refuse de croiser ce monsieur
parce que avez vous ajouté
il n'a pu bâtir sa fortune qu'en étant
le complice des généraux algériens
oui et je le maintiens eh bien je
maintiens cette affirmation
parce que monsieur khalifa qui est à la
tête d'une fortune colossale d'un
milliard de dollars à peu près qui a
payé et a pas très longtemps
quinze airbus rubis sur l'ongle il faut
quand même le faire à n'a pas pu bâtir
sa fortune dans un régime dictatorial
comme celui de l'algérie sans la
complicité du pouvoir et de l'argent
sale que l'on connaît en algérie qui
vient principalement du pétrole et de la
corruption c'est un régime qui je vous
le signale à produit à peu près 15
millions d'algériens de jeunes algériens
et d'autres qui vivent en dessous du
seuil de la pauvreté
et depuis 12 années où le processus
démocratique a été arrêté il ya eu deux
cent mille morts il ya beaucoup moins de
milliardaires que de mort en algérie
aujourd'hui vous refuser de le croiser
je refuse de le croiser parce que
j'estime que l'argent que son consortium
sa télé
sa compagnie aérienne ses produits
pharmaceutiques sa banque
ces voitures de location bref son empire
est un empire qui n'a pu être que
construit que dans le giron des généraux
c'est donc de blanchiment d'argent sale
d'ailleurs vous savez comment on appelle
rafik khalifa en algérie on l'appelle la
machine à laver alors pour me laver
l'argent sale il faut trouver des
lessiveuses il est en train d'en trouver
en france et c'est ça que je lui
reproche alors justement qui rafik
khalifa à qui nous avons demandé bien
évidemment d'être là ce soir mais qui
n'a pas souhaité venir
on l'appelle effectivement le
milliardaire algérien il est
propriétaire notamment de rallye fail
whale compagnie aérienne qui dessert
l'algérie il est sponsor du club de foot
l'om sponsor du club de rugby de bègles
donc dont vous êtes député maire il a
versé 600 dix mille euros sur deux
saisons
vous auriez préféré une souscription
mais ça n'aurait pas suffi parce
qu'aujourd'hui les les équipes
professionnelles ne sont plus des clubs
sont des entreprises et donc un choix
qui a été fait par ceux qui dirigent le
club aujourd'hui enfin parce qu'il
réussit à déneiger
c'est un choix sur lequel le maire de
bègles ne peux rien je n'ai rien à dire
parce que c'est une entreprise
alors au final vous vous étiez pas au
match
rafik khalifa non plus puisque il a dit
qu'il était officiellement retenu aux
états unis bon à faire il voyage
beaucoup il a beaucoup d'avis en bourse
à dents qui fascine mais alors il a un
ardent défenseur cearà fikrat l'ifa en
la personne de gérard depardieu qui est
son ami et que nouvel administrateur
gérard depardieu du club de rugby de
bègles et qui était l'invité vedette du
match samedi dernier
magnéto serge va peut-être chier dans
son froc en velours je suis peiné pour
lui et son parti parce que je pense que
les verts sont plus intelligents que ce
qu'il a dit est ce des propos qu'il a
tenus qui sont proches des propos
racistes et je dirais même un faux nom
c'est un peu agaçant il faudrait le
chasser de son parti écoutez franchement
un gérard depardieu j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui comme acteur donc
je recommande vivement de refaire du
cinéma c'est franchement là qu'il est le
meilleur mais comme businessman il est
pas très recommandable alors je suis
beaucoup plus blessée par les propos
qu'il tient sur moi en tant que raciste
fasciste parce que chacun connaît mes
engagements pour les droits de l'homme
et en particulier pour le peuple
algérien et contre ceux qui sont en
train de les asservir et de les torturer
et je trouve que il exagère un peu en
donnant ses leçons de morale parce qu'il
faut quand même savoir qui est gérard
depardieu comme homme d'affaires gérard
depardieu le lendemain du match
sa figure dans le journal el watan c'est
facile à trouver
avec un avion de khalifa airways il est
parti en algérie pour rendre visite aux
vignobles qui l'a achetée dans la région
de tlemcen
gérard depardieu c'est le garçon c'est
l'homme d'affaires qui avait que le roi
du poulet qui a été mis en examen et
condamné monsieur bourgoin a des
intérêts à cuba qui sera donc la manne
fidel castro qui est un autre dictateur
c'est aussi gérard depardieu qui est
allé en 1998 participer contre espèces
sonnantes et trébuchantes avec d'autres
vedettes à la campagne d'un sinistre
personnage un communiste recyclé dans le
nationalisme qui s'appelle vladimir
meciar quel premier ministre de
slovaquie
donc franchement est alors depardieu dit
une énormité
pour tous ceux qui connaissent un peu
l'algérie vous aussi vous êtes
journaliste il dit mais si le sig rafik
khalifa était ce que dit noël mamère ce
que dit toute l'algérie d'ailleurs la
presse l'aurait déjà démontré comme si
la presse algérienne n'était livrée
comme s'il pouvait y avoir une presse
libre en dictature franchement pour
vendre quelques bouteilles de vin
depardieu pousse quand même un peu le
bouchon très loin
bien bien entendu gardé par bear est le
bienvenu pour répondre sur ce plateau
oui mais vous savez c'est pas ben c'est
pas depardieu qui est intéressant dans
cette affaire c'est rallye faye le
régime algérien a affirmé gérard
depardieu dit effectivement en parlant
de rafik khalifa c'est un jeune homme
génial at il déclaré c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu le le tapis algérien
d'une certaine façon c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose je veux bien je veux
bien vous maniez cela terrain de tapis
pour me dire que j'étais sur sa liste
européenne sous la dent je vais de la
pêche
enfin écoutez moi tapie n'a jamais été
l'associé dans un gouvernement français
deux cent mille morts sur les mains qui
a du sang sur les mains
tapie il a peut-être des il a peut-être
des casseroles mais il n'a pas de sang
sur les mains comme le régime algérien
rafik khalifa est très généreux avec les
gens riches et célèbres et ses secrets
comme ça ne court il sait il s'est
acheté des gens célèbres et les amener à
des matches comme celui qui a eu lieu
sur le stade du 5-juillet cette année
france algérie ou à l'inauguration de
deux khalifa tv ou à des matchs de l'om
ce qui est beaucoup plus grave à mon
point de vue c'est qu'il est il est
soutenu en france par des lobbys
l'industriel et des lobbys économiques
très puissant mais compris des lobbys
politiques
oui c'est construit des réseaux comme ça
il a investi de l'argent dans le
magazine de 2 4 0
et quand il lance une chaîne de télé ce
qui a été le cas récemment à cannes il
invite la terre entière il se paye sting
le chanteur sting rechanter dans sa vie
la peau pour une soirée c'est assez payé
quelques artistes français mais il n'a
pas réussi à convaincre isabelle adjani
lui rendre hommage parce que elle elle
n'a elle n'a jamais fonctionné dans ce
système nous connaissons ses origines
algériennes ouais elle a failli se faire
rouler dans la farine par le système
algérien qui est extrêmement intelligent
extrêmement pervers lorsqu'elle est
arrivée en algérie en algérie elle eu le
courage de dire ce qu'était le régime
déchu
ayrault c'est à dire une dictature avec
une vitrine qui s'appelle bouteflika
alors la dernière idée de rafic rallye
face c'est de faire une ville nouvelle
en algérie qu'il veut faire dessiner par
ricardo bofill
et alors il a beaucoup d'humour ce
garçon parce que quand on lui pose la
question quand on lui dit mais d'où
vient votre argent il dit c'est l'argent
des saoudiens le blanchiment de l'argent
les militaires et s'il le faut le pavot
à mon avis sous forme de boutade il ne
fait que dire la vérité comment comment
vous pouvez expliquer que l'on soit à la
tête d'une fortune dévié lui évalué à
peu près un milliard de dollars en
commençant dans une petite officine de
pharmacie en 1990 les dix ans plus tard
avoir cette fortune en algérie vu le
système comme il est c'est pas possible
sans des sans des complicités sandé
complaisance et sans vraiment quelqu'un
de très répréhensibles comme vous le
dites
le gouvernement français ne laisserai
pas investir comme sponsor de l'om comme
ce pognon de bègles la france mène des
enquêtes notamment par la dst et moi je
vais demander à l'inspecteur des impôts
de bègles et au ministère des finances
de mener une enquête sur ce partenaire
d'un club français s'est plaint le cabbg
ce mariage pour moi est un mariage
contre nature
ça pose aussi avec ce que j'ai dit ça
pose ici le problème du mariage entre le
fric et le sport ouais alors nous
recevrons tout à l'heure noël mamère
monsieur mélenchon gauche socialiste
absolument anti anti blairiste anti
fabius anti dsk et qui a lancé avec
henri emmanuelli le mouvement nouveau
monde
chez les verts ça se passe pas mieux je
pense que on voit bien ce qui s'est
passé en allemagne avec le losc affiche
heures c'est à dire que quand les verts
sont unis quand ils sont disciplinés
ça fait gagner la gauche écoutez que je
pense que nous avons des leçons à tirer
de ce qui s'est passé chez les verts
allemands faut quand même aussi savoir
qu'il ya plusieurs conditions qui font
que les verts allemands ont réussi aussi
bien la première c'est que le système
électoral allemand fait que lorsque l'on
à sept et demi pour cent des voix ce qui
était notre camp 97 bas en allemagne en
a 55 députés
en france en a que 7 c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous demandons la réforme
du système de scrutin c'est passionel
assez mal barré pour ne rien vous cacher
la deuxième chose c'est que les sociaux
démocrates allemands ont beaucoup mieux
compris les verts allemands que les
socialistes français ont compris les
verts français si par exemple
aujourd'hui vous disiez un socialiste on
revient au pouvoir et on nomme un verre
ou une verte comme c'était le cas en
allemagne ministre de l'agriculture
ouais bah c'est la france couverte sous
le purin les fourches qui ressorte et
c'est la jeune kate moss et la jacquerie
paysanne aux fourches lesjak 1,6
apparaîtrait complètement incongru que
l'on nomme un verre ou une verte
ministre des affaires étrangères
donc je pense que cette c'est un
problème culturel que nous avons avec
les socialistes français et puis à la
différence des verts français les verts
allemands réussi à imposer des réformes
très importantes en allemagne alors
celle qui se voit le plus parce que
c'est la plus écolo c'est la sortie
progressive du nucléaire
et moi à mon avis ils ont été ils ont eu
un rôle encore plus important les verts
dans un sujet de société qui pour les
allemands quand on connaît leur histoire
récente est très important c'est le code
de la nationalité
c'est sous l'influencé des verts qu'on
est passé du droit du son au droit du
sol à nous on n'a pas réussi grand-chose
franchement dans mais en france ça se
passe beaucoup moins bien qu'en
allemagne les verts dominique voynet
s'en va ça fait on n'a pas des verts ale
sans vie sur le terrain oui mais bon je
prends du temporel pour vivre la raison
ouais là de revenir
bennahmias et pocrain vont bosser chez
europe 1 oui c'est tout seul
bah oui enfin tout seul dans les médias
c'est ça m'amuse parce qu'on disait sous
forme de boutade que j'aimais tellement
les médias que lorsque j'allais retirer
de l'argent dans les guichets
automatiques
je faisais des interviews aux caméras de
surveillance
[Musique]
m
voilà alors guillaume depardieu vous
nous avez rejoint donc je suis pas du
tout question d'un droit de réponse
puisque vous n'êtes pas gérard depardieu
vous êtes guillaume depardieu
mais est ce que votre père vous a
présenté rafik khalifa déjà non non
jamais non donc vous n'avez pas rien de
spécial a déclaré finalement non
monsieur commissaire alors guillaume
depardieu après tous les matins du monde
de cornaux en 91 cible émouvante et les
apprentis de salvadori en 93 et 95 après
pola x de leos carax en 99
vous êtes à la fiche de peau d'ange le
premier fils de vincent pérez avec vous
morgan mort et magali voc karine silla
olivier gourmet laurent terzieff
dominique blanc valeria bruni tedeschi
voulez que je fasse le pitch oui
j'aimerais bien parce que je suis pas
très doué alors c'est simple c'est
l'histoire d'angel qui est jouée par
morgan mort est une curieuse fille qui
vit dans la ferme paternelle dans un
milieu pauvre et défauts on va à la
messe le dimanche matin
et puis ses parents sont tellement
pauvres qu'ils doivent se résigner
envoyer leurs filles travaillé comme
bonne chez des notables de la ville
et là vous débarquez vous guillaume
depardieu vous êtes venu en fait pour
l'enterrement de votre mère mais vous
avez quitté la cérémonie pour boire un
verre parce que ça vous gonfle
voilà alors vous allez passer la nuit
ensemble pour elles c'est la première
fois qu'elle fait l'amour avec un garçon
c'est un don total elle s'abandonne
complètement alors que pour lui enfin
pau pour vous c'est plutôt une
consolation au passage leur nom
consolation passagère j'irai abandon
nécessaire plutôt c'est à dire qu'après
tout ce que je n'ai pas fait il fallait
que je fasse quelque chose
il fallait que je fasse quelques
semaines voilà donc après cette première
nuit ils se séparent sur un quai de gare
voila apres vont-ils se revoir que
va-t-il se passer magnéto serge rochelle
[Musique]
comment trouver les mots pour vous
parler d'un gel c'est pratiquement
impossible parce que justement angèle se
situe au dessus des mots
chaque fluence
chaque cellule
ça
que nous jouions aux autres fois seul
jeune âge ou maladroites similaires et
salle d'eau et des postes il me trompe
pas sur ces choses là moi j'entends son
nom j'ai la tête qui tourne bon écoute
et mademoiselle vous partez vous rêvez
je comprends rien je n'ai jamais entendu
parler d'angel du bois non et je la
connaissais à peine
j'ai vu juste une seule fois et à partir
de
quel degré de souffrance confiance aux
gens on ne peut pas oublier
pas faire comme tout le monde j'ai même
pas
moi je ne fais même pas ayant jamais
personne
j'ai horreur de guillaume depardieu
nous notre invité ce soir moi je vous
pouvez excellent dans ce film excellent
acteur ambiance déjà dans les films de
salvadori pis dans tous les matins du
monde répu le voir alors vous
connaissiez peut vincent perez
mais en fait la personne qui joue dans
le film d'ailleurs et qui a écrit le
scénario karine silla a été la maîtresse
de votre père gérard depardieu avec qui
elle a eu un enfant et c'est peut-être
pour cela qu'elle a le personnage est
tellement bien écrit vous correspond
tellement bien non non parce qu'il
n'était pas prévu pour moi au départ
donc
alors derrière à l'époque c'est à
l'occasion de la révélation de
l'existence de ce bébé
roxane que vous étiez allait tout casser
dans le hall d'accueil du magazine voici
7 il ya dix ans oui c'était bien ça vous
souvenez de sa hache c'était génial
j'ai pris un énorme standard le plus
gros qui avait gelé éclaté sur deux
vigiles un truc qui vaut cher et où il
avait sandrine bonnaire qui avait mis du
purin et du fumier web voici voilà dire
qu'à l'époque c'était il ya dix ans une
sale époque pour vous c'était à la fin
de la même année que vous êtes fait
choper en train de vendre de l'hérault a
la garde de vaucresson je n'étais pas en
train de vendre ces conneries c'est un
vrai danger je dépannais un copain parce
qu'on était tous dans la merde ce que ça
coûtait moins cher leur père dame donc
on allait à rotterdam en chêne m'acheter
est tout simplement parce que je voulais
pas demandé de l'argent à qui que ce
soit surtout pas mes parents ne savaient
même pas je me défoncer vous
[Musique]
d'être trouvée en taule
ouais longtemps oui et alors balattou
quoi en plus dur pascal mais où ça nous
a rendu plus agressif ça m'a rendu
antisocial à
c'est sûr
c'est ça
social
ce ressenti social vous dites mon danger
c'est que je n'ai jamais eu peur de
grand chose pas plus de la drogue que de
la prison les excès je connais ouais en
fait j'ai même pas peur de la mort parce
que en fait depuis tout petit ça ma
compagne tout ça c'est des choses qui ne
font pas peur elles vivent avec moi font
partie de moi je sais qu'un jeu ça fait
partie de ma vie je veux dire ça c'est
une philosophie
bon c'est ma philosophie ouais j'ai peur
de rien déjà 15 ans j'ai eu des
problèmes pour vol avec violence non
ouais je suis mon premier séjour en
prison ça c'était pas bien je ne suis
pas très fier ça c'est pas très fier
ouais c'est pas facile d'être le fils de
depardieu quand même non mais c'est
facile d'être fils de personne que bon
c'est bon j'ai dire j'ai eu les mêmes
difficultés que tout le monde mais sauf
que j'ai un caractère une nature qui
font que que ça se voit ouais vous avez
été bien élevés ou pas très bien parce
que votre père dit souvent qu'à l'époque
vous étiez il avait 20 ans c'était trois
ans avant les valseuses donc il était
encore dans un petit studio à malakoff
moi je compte je pense que mon père
devient lui-même maintenant en fait je
pense qu'il faut vraiment beaucoup de
temps pour faire un homme
il faut fois près 50 ans il faut c'est
long surtout un garçon c'est vrai vous
auriez préféré est le fils de delon
belmondo non non je suis très content
d'être le fils de mon père malgré tout
c'est tout c'est tout fait malgré ce que
dit ma mère quoi malgré ce que peut dire
ma mère que bonds a plus ma mère c'est
quelqu'un qui politiquement c'est quand
même ce que je trouve qu'ils se
rapprochent le plus de mon vocabulaire
époux façon de penser mais en même temps
j'ai très vite compris très tôt vers 16
ans que je ferais jamais vue plus
politique parce qu'au départ je voulais
en faire je voulais partir faire aller
en afrique mais faire la guérilla quoi
c'est à dire piquer tous les diamants et
rendre rendre le pognon à ce qui est qui
et qui
ils ont quoi c'est à dire le gaz au
pétrole les machins mais bon tout le
monde sait enfin j'espère que tout le
monde sait et j'espère que tout le sel
surtout les jeunes que les hommes
politiques n'ont aucun pouvoir
ouais c'est pas très juste ça pour ça
désolé mon cher noël mais vous n'avez
aucun pouvoir
c'est un peu caricatural vous le savez
très bien vous êtes à la merci d'un mot
vous êtes à la merci d'une phrase vous
êtes à la merci pour ces mots les mots
ici en des lyonnais s'était regardé
comment je viens d'esquisser passé la
déroute le machin
les soirs de conseillers vous êtes dans
un tourbillon vous êtes moins de tout
vous êtes finalement ce que je constate
avec monsieur khalifa puisque c'était
sale l'histoire c'est que j'ai j'ai
appris à fermer ma gueule parce que moi
j'ai j'ai jamais été d'accord vraiment
avec les choix de mon père
sur beaucoup de choses et politiques
surtout mais considérant que l'argent
domine le monde
si monsieur khalifa arrive à me prouver
qu'avec sa stratégie il arrivera à ce
que sa jeunesse ne baigne pas dans dans
ces morts dont vous parlez dans
l'islamisme et puisse rêver de travail
et d'espoir tout simplement rêver là je
veux dire qu importe le discours et la
méthode revue qu'on ait l'ivresse de la
dignité livre la dignité et la visite et
vous savez la dignité
ça peut aller très loin la dignité ainsi
elle parle de la dignité du peuple
algérien puisqu'il s'agit de lui vous
savez là bas ils sont très contents de
khalifa vers les jeunes
quelques-uns oui s'est défait de masse
et l'effet tapie lui il a réussi la
douleur et où il se trouve vous savez
l'algérie c'est un des pays les plus
jeunes du monde
la moyenne d'âge est de 23 à 25 ans ces
jeunes là aujourd'hui ils ont aucun
espoir
beaucoup d'entre eux d'ailleurs face à
cet ac à cette misère
je veux voir je veux voir l'islamisme
sur lequel d'ailleurs joue avec oui mais
ça c'est avec moi ce que je veux c'est
sentir des passions que je dis c'est que
des gens moi quand je veux savoir
quelque chose je vais sur place et il ya
une biographie autorisée de khalifa qui
est absolument extraordinaire que je
n'ai pas amené ici dans laquelle il est
dit qu'il fait beaucoup pour la
formation des jeunes
et qu'est-ce qu'ils forment ils forment
des pilotes d'avion vous croyez que les
jeunes les algériens sont nombreux à
subir des formations des pilotes d'avion
qui trouve tout ce que votre père a des
vignobles il ya quatre jeunes la semaine
dernière qui sont morts de botulisme
le botulisme c'est une maladie lié à la
pauvreté le coup de collier moi j'aime
les deux staphylocoque
france d'accord et j'avais dans ma
chambre je risque de perdre ma jambe
j'espère que vous ne verrez pas lancer
des cordes ans mais bon me d'écouté vous
pas du tout mais si vous dites en france
il ya des jeux du moment qu'il ya du
pognon regarder du moment qu'il ya du
pognon
est ce qu'on pourrait en employant les
mots et qui c'est qui gouvernent le
monde sait les états unis d'accord bon
alors à respecter que c'est pas que la
58e lyon s'il ya une bonne volonté
derrière moi je m'en fous moi je suis
pas cynique comme vous donc je dis je
dis que je saurai ce je vous laisse je
ne me résous pas à ce que ce soit les
puissances financières américaines ou
autres qui finance le monde est pour
vous dire sur la franchise d'accord avec
vous vous avez attrapé une maladie
nosocomiale pour employer un terme
pédant à l'hôpital mais vous savez qu'il
ya quand même des enfants qui vivent
dans les banlieues
peut-être qu'il ya des jeunes qui sinon
il ya des enfants qui attrapent des
maladies qui s'appelle le saturnisme
quand on vit dans des logements
insalubres
voilà donc c'est aussi la france est
aussi un pays dans lequel il ya des gens
pauvres dans lequel il ya des gens qui
vivent mal et nous devons nous battre
pour qu'ils vivent mieux c'est ça aussi
la noblesse depuis que j'ai l'âge c'est
parce qu'enfin il monsieur messier ni
monsieur ni monsieur mère qui est
aujourd'hui ministre des finances moi je
souhaitais simplement monsieur
j'ai eu ma mère que vous avez parlé trop
vite c'est tout moi j'aurais étudier le
dossier avant mais on le connaît bien le
dossier khalifa en effet mais moi j'ai
rien vu pour l'instant je vais vous
faire oublier tout ça
mais
[Musique]
mozart
tu es
le cabinet du requiem ouais la première
fois que guillaume depardieu entendu ce
morceau vous aviez 16 ans c'était un
soir de déprime vous ai mis cette
cassette complètement par hasard vous
avez beau couple aurait ce soir là et
vous avez décidé de changer votre vie et
huit jours après vous avez quitté
l'école voilà l'autre chose qui a changé
votre vie c'est votre fille louise
oui mais plus radicalement vrai parce
qu'au départ j'étais tout seul et puis
j'étais plein de rêves encore mais
j'aime mais là j'ai en fait ça me change
mais je pourrais même pas l'exprimer
parce que c'est je suis complètement
c'est comme quand on vient de se prendre
un coup à la pointe du menton je suis
sécher quoi je suis j'admire je peux
qu'admirer ça me ramène à des choses
face bouleversante veut du bien est ce
que le fait d'être père maintenant vous
rend plus indulgent envers votre père
oui mais j'avais déjà fait un peu de
travail là dessus quand même hein sinon
il y aurait eu mort d'homme
georges dandin son père
jamais
or dieu est notre invité ce soir
ça c'est la bande originale du jeu
avec carla bruni bâches
jean faure les rita mitsouko et fred qui
d'aston villa qui sera notre invité tout
à l'heure voilà on passe maintenant aux
rebondissements de la ferme et screen
avec lucien aimé blanc
lucien aimé-blanc bonsoir bonsoir donc
vous publié chez plon un livre qui
s'appelle la chasse à l'homme la vérité
sur la mort de mesrine essais signés
dans commissaire divisionnaire lucien
aimé blanc c'est vous vite à marseille
en 1935 votre père est mort à dachau
vous avez été nommé commissaire en 1962
en 1966 vous pourrez la direction de la
brigade anti gang en 74 la direction de
la brigade des stups
fais gaffe de marseille pour démonter la
french connection voilà et en 1977 vous
devenez commissaire divisionnaire à le
ca mais voilà et donc en 79 comme
mesrine est abattu vous êtes à la tête
de l'eau crb voilà donc les chiens mais
blanc vous publie la chasse à l'homme
que vous élections en collaboration avec
un ex de libé jean michel caradec 1
alors ça se lit comme un polar de la
série noire c'est vraiment passionnant
votre bouquin je conseille vraiment à
tout le monde quand ça commence vous
couvrez un casse ça c'est incroyable de
voir un grand flic comme ça qui couvre
un casse lucien aimé blanc est en train
de surveiller pendant toute une nuit une
propriété dans laquelle des truands sont
en train de dérober des lits meubles de
valeur et puis vous escorté jusqu'à 100
km de paris et vous les laisser partir
avec le butin à l'époque on était
complètement dans le vent malgré une
coordination malgré la mobilisation des
services de police mais ce qu'ils ne
savaient pas où ils étaient fallait leur
trouver donc grâce à des informateurs
j'ai réussi à retrouver sa piste et de
ses informateurs il fallait les payer
oui c'est henri leblond qui vous avez
aidé à retrouver power donc il fallait
le payer le ministère veut pas filer de
pognon on avait les termes
j'ai la spedidam avocat le ministère l'a
dit aimé blanc et les fonctionnaires
beaucoup de travail et leur foi de frais
de mission les 3 millions seront
affectés
vous avez la gloire vous ne rêviez
légion d'honneur ni l'argent bon il
fallait que je me débrouille pour payer
ses informateurs parce que si c'est fait
arrêter sur ce casque parce que ce cas
ci l'aurait fait quand même
mais puisque c'étaient des
professionnels il n'avait pas besoin de
moi pour faire ses classes mais en
vérité à mes petits commissariats côté
qui pouvait les gêner
et moi j'ai pensé que si je faisais
arrêter un il leur expliquait toute
l'histoire oui et là c'était une bombe
qui me seraient retrouvés donc voilà
c'est bien ce que je disais le bouquin
commencer vous surveillez 1 càs de le
regarder en assume complètement voilà
mais bien entendu inscriptions
maintenant tu risques je pense qu'ils
ont ils n'ont pas cassé un pauvre ouais
si c'est une bonne réponse un peu
peut-être de bonnes raisons dites moi à
l'époque tous les moyens étaient bons
pour venir à bout de mesrine dont même
les 10 les plus les plus malsains parce
que c'est l'époque où vraiment à la fin
mesrine était devenu un mythe d'un
personnage de légende vous raconter ça
très bien d'ailleurs
et justement c'était un type e robin des
bois mesrine ils étaient censés voler
aux riches pour donner aux pauvres
oui mesrine si vous voulez avec ses
complices se jouer un peu je cassidy et
le kid
il faisait plein de faits d'armé il
s'est fait arrêter en 73 il s'évade en
prenant en otage le président du
tribunal quand broussard l'art est il
offre le champagnes publie l'instinct de
mort qui est son autobiographie ça aussi
ça fait mal durant il a un procès en 77
qui est un véritable événement mondain
il jette les clés de sa cellule au
président du tribunal en disant voilà
dans votre prison tout s'achète
violent quoi il est condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle mais il s'évade de
la santé c'est quand même pas facile ils
braquent le cadre de vie libre à la
société générale du raincy de
l'interview à match ils kidnappent
l'industriel lelièvre et puis là
effectivement il commence à politiser
son discours la sécu hs bien sûr et puis
c'était au moment de la loi fameuse loi
peyrefitte sécurité et liberté la
liberté était une loi de rigolade deux
garçons demain à côté de celle de
sarkozy d'ailleurs
oui mais je sais pas si c'est pas des
effets d'annoncé aujourd'hui ce qu'on
aura enfin je saurai attention ça
m'intéresse plus oui mais après tu
arrives beaucoup il aimait beaucoup les
femmes un mesrine
je crois qu'il est je ne sais pas s'il
aimait les femmes plusieurs femmes mais
il a toujours eu des femmes qui étaient
devenus gelé ses complices et qui n'ont
jamais trahi c'est ce que je dis il
avait quelques équipes il fallait deux
équipiers de temps en temps mais il
avait cette qualité là qui de excusez
moi l'expression ne mouillez jamais ces
femmes il ne faisait pas braquer les
faisait pas la femme c'était le repos du
guerrier
si julien anouilh et comme tout le monde
il vous fait rêver mesrine mais c'est
non non c'est plutôt symbolique c'est un
bassin me rappelle une chanson de truste
d'ailleurs sur les qhs sur les choses
comme ça à bord
je ne sais pas
c'est une chanson de trace toujours
parole de mesrine s'appelle le mitard
oui vous connaissiez ça oui le mitard
aussi oui oui alors c'est un peu comme
dans les films à ce moment là la
hiérarchie s'impatiente un c'est un peu
comme on voit matignon on voit l'elysée
on voit le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur bonnet monsieur giscard
d'estaing s'impatiente et terriblement
et puis le 2 novembre 1979
l'appartement de mesrine et où il vit
avec sylvia jeanjacquot et localiser ces
rue belliard donc et un jour il sort de
cet appartement
la scène est célèbre dans une bmw 528
qui est bloquée place de clignancourt
par une fourgonnette bleue bâché d'où
quatre tireurs de l'antigang ouvre le
feu avec des carabines automatique et un
pistolet mitrailleur 19 blessures
mortelles pour mesrine et sa compagne
sylvia jeanjacquot grièvement blessés
voilà ça c'est la version 10 ont connu
des faits génération officiel en fait si
vous voulez je n'étais pas plus
responsable cette opération comme je
l'expliqué dans le bouquin puisque
monsieur boussaha commandait la berri et
été compétence eau paris ouais moi
j'avais le crb bon c'était un organisme
au niveau national et donc des cons
intervenez soit à paris soit à marseille
on était obligés d'être en assistance
avec le service compétent donc broussard
était compétent le directeur bien sûr
tout à fait a désigné monsieur moussa
pour conduire cette opération en me
disant mes côtés mais blanc compte tenu
du travail à des risques que vous avez
pris dans des manipulations un peu
spécial
il y plus tard qu'elles seront malsaine
mais il était bien content de les abîmer
passage
alors donc monsieur boussarie chargée de
cette opération et c'est lui qui est
entièrement responsable des opérations
alors voilà donc mesrine est abattu mort
d'une star pratiquement en direct les
policiers exulte devant l'objectif des
photographes
le ministre bonnet le président giscard
d'estaing sont effectivement satisfait
mais dès le lendemain la polémique est
lancée
ce que vous appelez page 229 de votre
livre la machine à fabriquer du doute se
met en marche
parce qu'effectivement s'il n'y a pas eu
de sommation
c'est un assassinat vous allez poser la
question de savoir s'il ya eu des
sommations voilà la famille porte
plainte
schématiquement immédiatement et
effectivement mesrine d'après ce qu'on
en sait en tous les cas ils étaient
assez calmes au volant de sa bmw et
sylvia jeanjacquot a déclaré quand la
bâche du camion s'est soulevé les hommes
armés étaient déjà en position et ils
ont tiré tout de suite ils ont pas fait
de sommations et alors le commissaire
broussard c'est là on en vient aux
points importants du livre de lucien
aimé-blanc le commissaire broussard le
patron de l'anti gang qui a battu
mesrine donc n'a jamais varié lui l'a
toujours dit la même chose il y à des
sommations
on a dit et répété qu' il y avait jamais
une sommation ce n'est pas vrai il ya
des braquages occupé le camp vers l'iss
avec l'âge et sa tenue police de bouge
pas avant il est figé sur son volant et
d'un seul coup il se penche sur sa
gauche et on constate sur précisément du
côté gauche il avait une petite sacoche
avec deux grenades défensives lumière
lucien aimé blanc vous affirmez dans
votre livre
robert broussard ne pouvait pas être
témoin de la fusillade et des
circonstances qui l'ont provoquée car il
était à ce moment précis assis à côté de
moi dans sa voiture garée à 50 mètres de
là est hors de vue de la scène grâce
vous annoncer à banon je confirme
complètement
nous étions dans la voiture du
commandement depuis le matin en été en
dans le périphérique un peu plus loin à
200 mètres de l'immeuble puis lorsque le
dispositif s'est mis en branle et est
logiquement broussard qui était au
volant - passagers puis avec
l'inspecteur derrière c'est cette
avancée vers la porte de clignancourt
car il avait donné des instructions pour
que la voiture de de mesrine ne dépasse
pas le feu rouge
il n'est pas hors de question d'aller
allait le suivre sur le périphérique on
savait pas où ils allaient puis
l'opération était embêté trop trop trop
aléatoires donc cette avancée sous la
rampe au niveau de la base qui n'a
encore une cinquantaine cinquantaine de
mètres à peu près on voyait rien et à ce
moment là la radio
le camion a fait savoir à monsieur
broussard qu'il était en place et que la
bm de mesrine était derrière
alors il a donné l'ordre d'intervention
il a dit intervenez les gens est abonnée
les gars ou allergies et les gars quand
enfin il a donné lors des interventions
à ce moment là les rafales ont éclaté
des rafales sèche courtes dont il venait
de sortir de la voiture et s'est
précipité sur la porte de clignancourt
pour rejoindre ses effectifs et mesrine
et aimant puisqu'il y avait pas il n'y a
pas eu de riposte le coup par coup il
n'y a pas eu de bruit de grenade puisque
vous savez qu'il avait des grenades dans
la voiture et moi je me suis je les suis
vite ou tout à fait tranquillement je
dois avouer je savais que c'était fini
je me suis pas précipité c'était lui qui
était responsable de ce dispositif
donc ce que vous affirmez aujourd'hui
lucien aimé blanc sait que le
commissaire broussard ne peut pas savoir
si des sommations ont été faites pas
plus que moyen mesrine a essayé
d'attraper des grenades offensives qui
était à l'inter de sa portière ou sous
son siège tout ce qu'il raconte c'est
pour couvrir ces mecs là je pense parce
que écouter un moment donné on était
dans la voiture tout il n'est pas sorti
de la voiture de commandement
et puis dans ses mémoires j'ai vu que un
moment donné au moment de la fusillade
finale il se mettait dans du camionnette
aménagée et je sais pas où était sa
caméra belge emile avait fallu qu'ils
ont débuté il était avec moi
point final je le confirme et puis c'est
très bien que je dis la vérité
on râle et voilà
on a enfin enfin une version à peu près
claire de ce qui s'est passé le 2
novembre 1979 à 15h15 à la porte de
clignancourt et on comprend évidemment
que le commissaire broussard a dit ça
pour couvrir ses troupes il vous
attaquent un endroit non non
dans sa parole contre la nôtre ou et non
puis je lui en veux pas moi je respecte
broussard je connais ses qualités
oui je crois qu'il croit d'ailleurs que
quand il a décidé de porter plainte en
diffamation
il a lu l'article de libération qui est
commissaire aimé blanc déclare que les
fonctionnaires de police la mairie en
tirer sans sommation mais moi je ne dis
pas qu'ils ont tiré sans sommation
je n'ai qu'il était avec moi donc il
faut même pas plus que moi en attendant
les solutions maintenant est-ce que les
sommations été faite alors en quête
rebondi de quoi satisfaire les enfants
de mesrine bruno boris et sabrina qui
affirment que leur père a été exécuté
voici sabrina et boris mesrine
bonsoir sabrina bonsoir boris vous venez
très rarement à la télévision j'ai
jamais vu je crois que c'est la première
fois
jamais on a beaucoup vu votre frère
bruno mais vous très rarement alors
sabrina le 2 novembre 1979
votre meilleur ami vous appelle au
téléphone et vous dis ils ont tué ton
père vous hurlez vous craquer et vous
partez porte de clignancourt où vous
voyez votre père le corps criblé de
balles et broussard heureux exultant
plus tard au quai des orfèvres
vous entendrez brousse à ouvrir le
champagne
il m'a même offert une coupe de
champagne que je vais jeter en plein
visage
en fait ils ont laissé mon père trois
heures à terre donc moi je suis arrivé à
ce moment là ils l'ont emmené j'ai suivi
jusqu'au quai des orfèvres j'ai pas pu
le revoir évidemment bon s'arrêter dans
une pièce à côté avec
ces hommes ils ont bu le champagne
ouais alors vous goristes le 2 novembre
1979 à 15h15 vous regarder un dessin
animé à la télévision et puis il
subitement le programme s'arrête et puis
d'un coup comme ça sur un écran en fond
vert il ya une photo qui apparaît et une
voix qui dit jacques mesrine a été
abattu à ce moment-là tout s'effondre et
vous réalisez que vous ne connaîtrez
jamais votre père et que vous ne serez
comme vous dites jamais si je vous aime
exactement donc c'est en regardant la
télévision en grande étant enfant que
j'ai appris l'allemand de le dessiner
mon père est tout et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là pour moi tout s'est effondré
parce que les questions qu'on peut avoir
pour un enfant qui avait jamais connu
son père je sais qu'à ce moment là bas
c'est fini j'aurais jamais les réponses
à mes questions et je sais que j'aurai
jamais un contact avec mon père vous
êtes heureux finalement de ne pas avoir
été à paris ce jour-là parce que vous
l'auriez vu et vous pensez que ça a été
encore plus dur d'après ce que vous en a
dit sabrina
oui je pense que je pense que un enfant
c'est pas la meilleure place de voir son
père qu en tout cas lors il ya trois
mois vous avez rallier le combat de
sabrina ouais jusque là pourquoi vous
étiez pas impliqués dans cette recherche
je dirais de la vérité parce que j'irai
la famille m'a énormément protéger toute
mon enfance qui ont commandé trois
autres enfants et tous et ils en ont
fait leur maximum pour me protéger de
cette paire l'un est comme ma soeur m'a
contacté pour parler de la procédure qui
était en cours j'ai eu les mêmes amis
rallier parce que ça me permettait
d'avoir une identité et des pouvoirs
aussi indirectement me rapprocher de mon
père séverine à vous vous avez porté
plainte pour assassinat dix jours après
la fusillade mais tina contre l'état ça
fait donc 24 ans ouais bon genou change
de juge à chaque fois ouais comme par
hasard je suis là seulement parce que
monsieur aimé blanc et là ce soir
ouais et qui me regardent enfin dans les
yeux que ce que tu veux tu tout à
l'heure vous tournez la tête moi je vous
regarde et que vous nous dites qu'il ya
pas une sommation dans des jouets audio
une chose déjà nous avons un point
commun c'est à dire que tout à l'heure
vous dites que vous avez jamais connu de
votre père vous avez à 19 ans perdu
l'autre moi j'ai perdu mon père en
allemand il a été tué quand les
allemands
je suis pas point commun si vous voulez
qui a perdu son frère c'est que le sens
des français
bon je suis pas en train de dire vous
avez perdu votre père de su r peu
importe
malheureusement c'est comme ça je suis
en train de vous dire vous étiez sur les
lieux je suis là pro là ce soir pour
vous regarder dans les yeux
d'accord et que vous me disiez qu'il n'y
a pas eu de sommation s'il n'y a pas eu
de sommation monsieur aimé blanc il ya
eu assassinat
je suis là que pour la ce soir vous êtes
là parce que vous avez créé un bouquin
moi je n'ai pas écrit un bouquin sur mon
père d'accord parce que le thème mairie
ne m'intéresse pas c'est mon père on n'a
pas ça signer jacques mirin ce jour-là
on assassine et que mon père donc vous
regarder dans les yeux
vous avez écrit un bouquin sur lui donc
ça vous intéresse sanka vous intéresse
vous vous regardez dans les yeux ce soir
et vous me dites il n'y a pas eu de
sommation s'il n'y a pas une sommation
il ya eu assassinat
je peux pas vous dire qu'apple de ce
match oliv69 dit mais non je peux pas
vous dire puisque je n'étais pas là
monsieur brou sort n'était pas là et les
personnes à la rue
avec les inspecteurs bon peut-être
ont-ils fait des sommations de sérieuses
zones qui ne vous est faite puisque
depuis vingt trois ans à lui il ya
certainement du sérieux doutes qui ne
disait pas fait mais c'est aux
magistrats instructeurs a déclaré la
vérité moi je peux pas vous dire où il
passa dans le cuivre
qu'est ce que je dis dans mon vient pas
une sommation ah non je ne dis pas que
peu de ce qu'on savait très bien qu'elle
existe que bruce à la vue des sommations
puisqu'il était avec vous la même chose
à la volée a réagi immédiatement
2 il a été placé vous avez attendu 24
ans tout d'un coup pour dire tout d'un
coup il ya peut-être pas eu sommation ça
fait 24 ans que je me bats vous avez
attendu 24 en bout
maintenant les cépages est patent du 24
ans d'histoire personnelle je raconte
une histoire que j'ai vécu
professionnellement et je le début de
cette histoire explique peut-être la fin
voici un jeu ciel et blanc est ce que
vous comprenez ce que sabrina vous dis
là ce soir
ça veut dire que si dans les yeux vous
lui dites qu a pas eu de sommation pour
elle pour lui c'est une réhabilitation
pour leur père pourquoi l'importance que
ça pas dit ça j'ai 24 ans qu'ils
essayent je n'étais pas mal
restaurateurs ne peut pas dire je
n'étais pas les inspecteurs donc je ne
peux pas dire qu'un cap a eu de
sommation en revanche ce que je peux
dire c'est que il ya des doutes sur ce
fait qu'ils aient pas eu de sommation ya
de sérieux doutes
la place que vous aviez à cette époque
je pensais quand même très importante
vous le savez s'il ya une sommation ou
pas sommation mais je t'ai pas que je
commande n'est pas bien ce n'était là
c'est moi qui avais commandé dispositif
je vous dirai pas plus de sommation
d'ailleurs je dis dans mon fils dans mon
livre que peut-être je vais donner aux
ordres inspecteurs de tirer les premiers
mais comme c'est pas moi qui commandait
je ne peux pas vous dire chahut des
sommations pas parce que dès que le taux
d'intervention a été donnée par
broussard la radio c'est tout y est a eu
des rafales terminée enfin de toute
façon c'est quand même un assassinat
monsieur aimé blanc on tire pas 19
balles dans les corps d'un homme une
balle dans la tempe à bout portant
je pense que c'est quand même un
assassinat c'est de l'abattage
je pense que c'était mal fait malmener
mais la difficulté c'est qu'il est mais
comme j'ai expliqué qu'il n'avait
peut-être pas d'autres occasions il y
avait une pression du politique
ce concert a eu des occasions dans sa
vie de l'arrêter avec le champagne
encore une fois et ray champagne six
mois et coûté je n'avais pas de haine
pour autant faire je ne connaissais pas
j'ai jamais vu sinon à la fin quand vous
avez pas pu montrer quelque chose à tous
pensent que mesrine a été exécuté par
par la police parce qu'il y avait des
ordres des politiques parce qu'il était
devenu très gênant donc cantonné dans un
état de droit
même les assassins ce qui était le cas
de mesrine hongrois a le respect de
l'état de droit c'est à dire à des
sommations lorsqu'il y à un guet-apens
qui est fait par les services de police
c'est ça l'état de rupture lvlm à
peut-être qu'ils se sont procurées ben
je sais pas ce qu'il aurait fait
peut-être qu'il aurait pris sa choré
n'allez peut-être qu'il aurait été qu'il
aurait été tué lors d'une altercation
avec la police mais selon la meilleure
manière pour l'état de droit de se faire
respecter c'est de respecter y compris
ceux qui se met en dehors de ces règles
donc mesrine s'était mis en dehors des
règles de l'état de droit
il a tué des gens mais en même temps je
pense que ce qui s'est passé avec
mesrine j'étais journaliste à l'époque
pour nous tous c'était évident qu'il
s'agissait d'une exécution
c'est vrai que ce sera très difficile
pour les enfants de jacques mesrine
d'obtenir gain de cause parce qu'on sait
très bien que dans ces circonstances là
l'état ne reconnaît jamais sa faute bien
donc lucien aimé-blanc vous ne pouvez
pas dire à sabrina mesrine en la
regardant dans les yeux il n'y a pas une
sommation
je peux pas je n'étais pas sur plate ne
peut pas pousser non plus après arrivera
ce qui nous bat trésor lui dit clame
sommation se sont pour le commissaire
broussard est invité sur ce plateau la
semaine prochaine s'il veut répondre à
ce qui a été dit à son sujet ce soir
voilà merci d'être venus ainsi tenir son
rang
mais
l'appelant julie delpy
[Applaudissements]
jugé depuis bon soir vous connaissez ah
oui
ah oui c'est noël mamère bonjour bonsoir
il est 'vert' ma mère ça va donc on vous
a vu julie lundi dernier sur france 3
dans la passion béatrice de tavernier
film qui date de 87 et on vous verra
demain soir dimanche sur france 2 dans
un épisode d'urgences où vous jouez
voilà voilà deux diffusions à une
semaine d'intervalle qui résume votre
vie oui très différente des choses très
différentes
alors d'abord la carrière française vous
êtes fille de comédiens exactement
commun comme guillaume vous avez fait
votre premier film à 7 ans brigitte
fossé où ça a quel âge ou votre première
apparition à l'écran bio 18 ans à 17 ans
en faisant vous tuez topor qui est un
ami que vos parents comme copie ou
arrabal dans un court métrage 1 14 ans
vous êtes dans détective le film de jean
luc godard on s'est vraiment très très
précoce et puis après mauvais sang de
leos carax donc avant la passion
béatrice de tavernier ça s'est passé
comment avec les oscars ac
c'était il ya très longtemps je m'en
souviens très peu mais
formidablement bien oui non non c'était
un peu dur c'est normal oui moi aussi
c'est comme il a fait pola x
je vous les comparez vos expériences
parce que j'avais 15 ans au site et ses
ponts de vie différemment les choses je
pense que maintenant je pense que je
vais pas du tout disons que maintenant
j'ai une distance et je pense qu on a 15
ans n'a pas l'humour ou la distance
qu'on peut avoir après plus tard dans la
file donc voici comment un tournage de
pola x e guillaume même moi j'ai été
plus âgé qu'elle mais j'avais toujours
pas distancer pas d'humour dont j'étais
dur apparemment j'ai peut-être raté le
truc je sais pas il sait qu'elle devrait
peut-être en vieillissant leos carax ah
non la franqui n'empire
c'est vrai que j'avais je comprends vous
preniez un certain nombre de précautions
par rapport à ce que vous dites parce
que vous avez une vraie réputation de r2
[Musique]
ça remonte à l'école en ce qui vous
concerne
oui d'ailleurs oui c'était pas tomber à
coucher devenu arif n'ont sinon quand
j'étais tout petit
mais vous êtes une jolie emmerdeuse donc
tout va bien merci alors qu'il s'était
passé quoi sur le plateau du tavernier
là la passion béatrice avec d'un an
pierre donnadieu vous avez fait quoi
vous avez beaucoup
non mais moi moi c'est à dire que non ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est que
c'était très dur ça ce n'est vraiment
pas de moi je crois sur la passion mais
je veux dire c'était un tournage très
très difficile il y avait beaucoup de
tension et je pense que ça s'exprime
comme ça mais je me suis très bien
entendu avec bertrand ça s'est très bien
passé
ouais on dit vous êtes une emmerdeuse
une grande gueule enfin vous dit des
trucs que tout le monde sait vous dites
que leos carax et paumé sais pas si je
sais que mathilda may n'est pas une
comédienne ça c'est pas c'est pas très
gentil en plus grandissant avec humour
justement est pas méchamment et que ça a
été tu rentres ans transformé
j'avais quoi 4 va passer oui c'est vrai
faut dire à sa décharge il ya très très
longtemps
oui je suis en non valeur en parlais
tout à l'heure de l'éducation que les
parents de guillaume lui en donner est
ce que vous vous avez été éduqués par
des parents complètement baba non pas
mal baba maal abah abah pas mal cool des
gens assez
des gens plat pas sans inhibition et
libre à c'est un peu un peu anar voilà
c'était bien oui c'est bien google enfin
tout quoi donc voilà les chats font pas
des chiens ouais c'est ce qu'ils disent
souvent lui alors à un moment vous
trouvez un petit peu grillé en france et
vous décidez de vous exiler aux usa
et je
cette partie sur un coup de tête en fait
je suis parti parce que déjà je voulais
voir l'amérique c'est vrai je voulais
partir en voyage d'abord à 17 ans je
suis parti juste visité les états unis
puis après j'ai décidé de faire des
études de cinéma à new york universités
donc j'y suis parti à 21 ans et ensuite
je suis parti à los angeles pour tourner
un film qui s'appelle killing zoe et en
fait ça fait neuf ans que j'y suis
killing zoe donc avec jean hugues
anglade before sunrise et puis
évidemment nicole dans urgences et vous
dites d'ailleurs si j'étais aussi
chiante qu'on veut bien le dire
pourquoi les américains meurent est il
engagé pour leur sens quand des gens dit
que je suis chiante cesser complètement
enfin moi je pense que c'est faux je ne
peux pas me défendre ce que je m'en fout
d'ailleurs si j'étais chiante je le
dirai je suis chiant tout ça mais mais
mais mais non je dis ce que je pense
c'est pas chiant de crise que je pense
quand tu quand ça vient au niveau du
travail
je veux dire je pense pas que j'aurais
pu être urgent si justement j'étais pas
guillaume je vais vous laisser partir
d'accord avec un petit peu mal à la
jambe la merci en tous les cas elle est
devenue merci
tiens tiens
il est pas mal ton fils gg ça vous fait
chier que les gens pensent que vous êtes
une chieuse et ça me gêne pas en fait un
hommage c'est juste que je trouve pas
que celui-ci chante que ça je pense que
je dis ce que je pense que je m'exprime
d'une manière très directe aux gens et
des fois ça froisse un peu mais mais
mais de dire que je suis chiant je pense
que c'est pas mal je pense que c'est pas
sympa non là elle s'exprime avec les
volubiles
voilà là c'est le premier constat qu'on
peut faire rallyes sympathiques
elle a un très beau visage est encore
plus beau à la caméra donc elle est
faite pour ça vous êtes et ce que vous
connaissez pas c'est mon nouveau truc
c'est qu elle age et un nouveau truc
regarde
[Musique]
où
tiago qui fait des images super c'est le
monde moderne
alors vous êtes julie delpy ici ce soir
pour votre premier film en tant que
réalisatrice qui passe au cinéma
accatone rue cujas à paris dans le 5e et
c'est une sorte de documentaire en temps
réel qui dure 24 heures alors je vais
faire le pitch fait le pitch allez-y
maintenant vivant à los angeles vous
êtes une spécialiste en pitch m'enfin
bon donc c'est l'anniversaire de vecchi
jouée par emilie wagner qui est organisé
par son ami al
c'est à dire vous et le frère devait
film tout un film tout ce qui se passe
même l'érection du chien le seul
problème c'est que manquent à l'appel
jimmy votre boyfriend et là commence une
recherche en fait tous fixés cet espèce
de road movie pour retrouver ce jimmy on
va là c'est un road movie et c'est un
film sur sur la névrose et sur
l'obsessionnel c'est à dire sur une
femme qui est incapable de lâcher prise
et fait c'est une comédie mais en fait
c'est marrant hier il y avait une
projection tout ça et en sortant les
gens disaient c'est une comédie mais
c'est quand même très angoissant parce
que c'est quand même sur l'obsessionnel
sur les gens qui sont pas capables de
vivre seul et c'est fait j'ai voulu le
faire en fait j'avais un scénario très
écrits etc
j'ai travaillé travaillé avec des
comédiens pendant plusieurs mois et puis
après j'ai eu on a tourné sur 24 heures
comme des fous j'ai vraiment choisi de
faire comme ça pour casser un peu tous
les codes sas et on a vraiment 24 heures
donc finalement c'est en chantant et en
touchant une grenouille séchées
retrouver dans le casier du vidéo club
où il bosse qu'un dénommé puma
découvrira que jimmy joue aux boules en
france
[Rires]
la star
on voit le king of jimmy réalisé par
julie delpy et leurs invités ce soir
donc parfaitement dans ce film on voit
bien oui c'est filmé en vidéo est pas
spécialement
vous êtes toujours jolie ambiance ouais
ouais mais sa fin de saison je voulais
faire ce soit le plus naturel possible
plus c'est à dire j'avais l'occasion de
faire un film conventionnel pour mon
premier film et j'étais en train de
monter le film et ça prenait beaucoup de
temps et puis j'ai dix fois que tu vas
genre ça veut dire je jette tout tout ce
que j'aimerais l'école en français je
m'en branle quoi je vais tout jeter tout
ce que tu as appris à l'école tout ce
que j'ai appris dans les séminaires
d'écriture tout ça et je vais faire un
film complètement comme comme moi je
sens le monde autour de moi c'est à dire
en une sorte de frénésie et voilà c'est
ce que je voulais faire ça vous branche
les verts allaient vers oui oui beaucoup
enfin moi je suis très concerné par
l'environnement je pense que c'est un
problème essentiel est que notre
président je dis notre leur que nous
avons là bas en amérique se fout
éperdument complètement
c'est à dire celles qui se ressemblent m
il a réservé aux griots il préfère les
pétroliers aux écologistes
oui non il a aucun intérêt d'ailleurs
pour que le monde continue à aa
subsister d'ailleurs il s'en fout
complètement de 900 ans totalement mais
il ya quand même il faut quand même
savoir que aux états unis mais julie
delpy le sait mieux que moi
il ya des mouvements de contestation
avec des mouvements écologistes très
très puissant et très fort par exemple
ils ont réussi à empêcher le congrès de
répondre à la demande de bouche qui
voulut des sanctuariser l'alaska pour y
rechercher du pétrole ont fini par
gagner quand même sont bien battus donc
on peut vaincre bouchon peut l'empêcher
de faire la guerre contre l'irak marion
rolland est bien sûr non mais il ya
plein de mouvements il ya plein de
soulèvements aux états unis contre bush
en ce moment là il y en a depuis qu'il a
été élu jeudi
bien donc comme vous vivez en amérique
la plupart du temps julie delpy on va
vous faire une interview c'est mieux en
amérique
[Musique]
alors bientôt
non parce qu'il y en a partout sur les
voitures en ce moment en amérique gabon
allons-y
c'est mieux en amérique la télé j'ai pas
la télé en amérique je vais pas j'ai une
télé gauche mais des cassettes la bouffe
très bonne en tout cas à los angeles il
ya de très très bons restaurants surtout
japonais mais la bouffe française les
marchés en france rien ne sera jamais
remplacée par ça les flics c'est mieux
en amérique
je crois que des deux côtés
bof quoi c'est un sarkozy nous
maintenant ouais sympa les mecs c'est
mieux en amérique a passé bien c'est
sympa il y en a plein ses coûts là ouais
[Applaudissements]
de toutes les races et toutes les
religions etc là bas ils sont sportifs
en plus en californie c'est un bonheur
un oui enfin c'est pas forcément ça que
j'aime n'ont plus tôt l' inverse mais
non en fait je ne suis pas fait pour
brest en parlant des films pornos sémian
numérique a j'en ai pas vus ah ben non
non j'ai pas regardé je suis pas très
branché films pornos donc enfin je vais
assez prude d'une certaine façon parce
qu' une des raisons que vous donniez à
votre départ aux états unis
c'était dire qu'en fait en france
avaient refusé de passer à la casserole
ah ben ça dépend avec qui passer à la
casserole
j'ai bossé d'accord non à huy pour
bosser bas ça évidemment ça a été très
très rigoureux je suis assez oui je suis
assez un j'aime j'aime l'intégrité jeu
mais ça je veux dire il plein de gens
heureusement dans le métier sont les psy
c'est bien en amérique
non je les préfère en france ah ben
ouais donc j'avoue que la dame si chaque
fois que julie raconter sa vie a senti
voulait appeler la police
non mais ils sont très à la lettre c'est
à dire si on leur dit à celui là je le
hais je vais le tuer ils se disent elle
va faire quoi
voilà la nuit s'est mis en amérique a
maintenant à los angeles à 10 heures et
demie du soir on est au lit ah bon oui
vous traînez pas dans les bars et des
barres de son nom mais un petit peu mais
pas vraiment on en est c'est pas
vraiment une ville de nuits saint vil
moi je suis debout à 6h30 du matin
les ragots c'est mieux en amérique les
ragots je suis pas très ragoûtant ragots
terrible sur vous lundi vous aviez une
affaire avec jack nicholson
ah oui alors ça ce n'est plus faux on
peut pas faire bien sûr c'est pas du
tout votre type non non c'est pas vous
avez déclaré que les mêmes jamais fait
la bise peut-être oui je sais plus j'ai
peut-être fait la bise en disant bonjour
mais je crois pas non je crois pas j'ai
serré la main je pense qu'on est dans le
monde du spectacle sans avoir toujours
droit des gens extrêmement avec
différents voix julie delpy bloc party
me soit entre
en tant que réalisatrice
m
j'accueille maintenant dieudonné
[Applaudissements]
m
ça va encore se permettre en paix vous
êtes américaine autrement j'aurais aimé
y ai pas peur chez les messieurs alors
encore leur a un petit peu plus tard
mais il faut dire que c'est un des
costumes
ce spectacle j'ai complètement
repositionné mon image et ses assesseurs
s'étaient pris le conseil en
communication de robert hue mais à dix
avec ça normalement tu vas pouvoir
refaire des émissions culturelles
[Applaudissements]
bien entre les cages de l'histoire est
en train de vous donner raison
parce que j'ai vu cette semaine la une
du figaro qui expliquait finalement que
c'est pour diversifier leur
approvisionnement en pétrole que les
états unis de george bush voulait
attaquer l'irak
donc voilà donc ça veut dire que vous
vous disiez ça il ya quelques mois tout
le monde vous tomber dessus
et puis maintenant l'histoire vous donne
raison je vous remercie vous étiez le
seul à pouvoir pouvoir m'a vite et
encore dans une émission de télé s'il
10h c'est que tout le monde peut dire ce
qu'il a à dire même si je suis pas
toujours d'accord les gens peuvent
parler voilà donc je suis assez
appréciable parce que ça a été assez le
boycott généralisé donc la bomba ça fait
plaisir merci donc l'histoire vous donne
raison d'une certaine façon
bah oui on voit enfin on voit
aujourd'hui chaque jour cette arrogance
américaine continue à repenser pas le
peuple américain est otage de ceux de ce
pouvoir
mais oui bien précisé qu'on peut être
anti bush sans être anti américains sur
la scène encore faut-il le dire parce
que les amalgames sont vite fait comme
ça et on peut ne pas apprécier sharon et
ne pas être antisémite voilà par exemple
est ce que j'ai une gueule d'antisémite
sont très très très anti sharon oui oui
vraiment très anti char alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes d'accord avec
jacques chirac finalement déjà donné
ouais ouais moi je trouve qu'il soit je
trouve qu'il a une attitude assez oui
mais son refus si je pense qu'il n'y ait
plus d'ambiguïtés dans sa position que
l'ancien du chancelier allemand
chancelier allemand sous la pression des
verts d'ailleurs notamment de fisher a
dit de manière très claire il n'y aura
nous sommes contre une intervention
américaine en irak y compris avec le feu
vert de l'onu way or la chiraquie ne dit
pas tout à fait la même chose et en plus
à l'assemblée nationale il accepte que
l'on ait un débat sur l'irak mais il a
recommandé au président de l'assemblée
nationale que ce ne soit pas sanctionné
par un vote
moi je n'accepterai pas je trouve que de
la même manière qu'on l'envoyait troupes
en afghanistan sans être consultés je ne
vois pas au nom de quoi l'exécutif pour
envoyer les troupes françaises en irak
sans que la représentation nationale
soit consulté je pense que sa position
est ambiguë voilà je donne est donc
maintenant tout le monde est d'accord
avec vous cette nature un vrai beau
enfin terne en france était un peu pour
avoir dit ce qu'on est en train de dire
là ça a été un petit peu aussi prononcé
contre la guerre américaine en
afghanistan et j'ai été très sévèrement
critiqué parce que j'ai dit que c'était
une guerre contre le peuple afghan je
maintiens que cette opération n'était
pas d'idée par les meilleures intentions
mais bush il a fait quelque chose de
très malin même si je pense que c'est un
monstre c'est qu'il a dit vous êtes avec
nous ou contre nous c'est à dire il a
transformé le monde en noir et blanc
c'est à dire on n'avait pas le droit
d'être pas forcément pro ben laden si on
était il fallait choisir quand on met
vraiment donc j'ai donné vos prises de
position au printemps dernier vous ont
amené à arrêter votre campagne
présidentielle on regrette que vous
n'ayez pas été président parce que vous
auriez sans doute revaloriser le smic
plutôt que les salaires des ministres
mais c'est clair que j'avais quelques
mesures à mettre en place pour je
pensais aussi que bon il y avait un
rapprochement possible au second tour
avec noël j'étais persuadé qu'on
arriverait peut-être en tête mais bon ça
c'est pas organisé de cette façon là bon
c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est
regrettable est que la classe politique
devrait accepter à la tribune des libres
penseurs parce que le vote contestataire
c'est le pen qu'il a pris 1 pour son
compte et je pense qu'à gauche il y
avait possibilité aussi de rassembler
des gens qui ne se sont pas mobilisés au
premier tour ce qui fait que le bon ben
laden n'aurait peut-être pas été ce
qu'on tourne alors je devais si vous
aviez été président vous auriez interdit
le front national
allez moi je sais pas si j'aurai
interdit le front national dont je pense
pas que j'aurai un père dit le front
national
je pense que c'est une grosse bêtise que
de dire qu'il faut interdire le front
national ça me rappelle ce qu'avait dit
bertold brecht au aux allemands à la
dictature allemande en 53 lorsque le
peuple s'était soulevée il avait dit si
vous n'aimez pas le peuple changer de
peuple interdire le front national c'est
non seulement faire de le père d'une
victime qui s'empêchent qui ce qui très
vite jours et là dessus et puis s'est
transformé en pestiféré les gens qui
votent pour lui donc le problème c'est
pas d'interdire le front national c'est
de faire que par exemple la gauche aille
vers ceux qui ont voté pour le front
national c'est qu'elle fasse une
politique de gauche
j'ai donné si vous aviez été prise en
mains publiques vous auriez amnistié
david douillet c'est un grand champion
que moi j'ai fait du judo pendant 15 ans
je dois dire que c'est quand même un
sacré champion ps que vous auriez épouse
et bernadette chirac pour qu'elle reste
la première dame de france
je suis je suis marié j'ai une épouse
c'est vrai que bernadette a des
avantages aussi à ses charmes
non mais c'est clair que j'aurais pu
blesser de tenter là encore je dirais
qu'on ne s'est pas rencontrés mais je
vous cache pas que ya un côté coquin
dans son slip
on n'a pas laissé de marbre jeu de mai
si vous aviez été président est ce que
vous auriez favoriser le lobby noir non
je suis ni blanc ni noir je suis je suis
un humain sur sept mais je suis contre
les frontières quelle quelle qu'elle
soit ethnique religieuse géographique
national je me bats contre les lobbys il
en existe il en existe et je trouve ça
regrettable
est ce que vous vous seriez balader les
couilles à l'air au fort de brégançon
j'aurais fait plus fort
alors pour le moment dieudonné vous êtes
au théâtre théâtre de la main d'or votre
théâtre où depuis le 24 septembre vous
présenter un nouveau spectacle qui
s'appelle le divorce de patrick ben ça
s'est passé en fait c'était cet été j'ai
un ami qui vont qui était dans une
période difficile de sa vie divorce sa
femme par les parties et que les enfants
alors j'ai été un petit peu le petit peu
son conte son confident et donc mon
objectif c'était de le faire rire ce qui
était pas évident et donc j'ai travaillé
pour cela et puis ça a donné ce
spectacle alors vous jouez dans ce
spectacle votre propre personnage vous
êtes invités à une soirée de gala dont
le thème est la femme
vous êtes dans les coulisses vous
attendez pour réciter un poème et
pendant ce temps donc vous êtes sans
cesse dérangé par patrick ce qui donne
le titre à la pièce qu'ils aient quitté
par sa femme et qui vous raconte ça au
téléphone c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé j'exagère georges olive c'est un
peu caricatural mais je pense que c est
bon je vous incite ceux qu'il divorce ou
qui sont dans des situations sensibles
de venir voir et de rigoler parce qu'en
fait je pense que c'est un moment dans
la vie où il est important de trouver un
peu d'autodérision parce que c'est ce
qui manque
il est sûr de sérieux comme ça il faut
qu'il y en ait un qui porte la
culpabilité alors que finalement une
aventure de vie c'est classique c'est
banal magnéto serge depuis ce matin
toute façon la lame la vie pour ça
raconte les prénoms bizarres
juste avant à vous qui a délibérément
des la juste avant la crise et des
galettes d'arrêt marqué pour un noir
savamment de la bombe ou là
c'est choquant bambula s'y essayèrent
que j'ai sorti un petit oussama de sa
tanière de chercher il voulait pas
sortir
il était enfant il était plongé
j'ai puisé 1001 pattes binôme a mordu il
n'y a pas de dents et ses principes kato
l'a d'ailleurs j'ai pris un conseiller
en communications ag prix même que
robert hue le mec il était libre il m'a
dit vas-y toi pousser la barbe à eux je
ne sais pas pourquoi mais moreno
septembre que je fais ça battles et
donnez moi les bombes c'est un petit peu
chaud là un fait chaud ouais tu avais
ouvrait la porte thérèse la porte du
couloir va mettre un petit peu un petit
courant d'air ça va faire du bien si si
si si mais non c'est très bien tiens les
imada me la fait pleurer les pattes ça
va vous rafraîchir le gosier
mais non les gens vont pas regardé par
câble
toute façon c'est pas le jour pour faire
cette roquette pas madame le faire
alors pour le coup la mise en plis là
vous êtes encore en suspens après narre
avec celle ci je me tiens pélardon
rebelles moi je vais pouvoir faire les
éloges sur tf1 je la mets
théâtre de la main d'or pour son nouveau
spectacle qui s'appelle le divorce de
patrick le lay messieurs je suis depuis
le 24 septembre les gens sont morts de
rire ça se passe plutôt bien je m'amuse
bien moi aussi alors vous abordez
également le thème de la mort dans votre
dans votre spectacle yeux et comme il ya
beaucoup de gens qui souhaitent votre
mort de données je vais vous faire une
interview la mort vous va si bien
le blindé sur celle de nommer un autre
accessoire qui nous attend sur 7
[Musique]
bien qu'en savez vous êtes mort yes
ça se passe pas mal vous voulez quoi
comme musique pour votre enterrement à
claude de garou je pense que je prendrai
bien dansez sur moi c'est sur moi le
soir de vos fiançailles que votre vie
soit feu d'artifice et ma mort un feu de
paille
vous êtes triste est mort or ça fait
chier pour ceux qui restent bons vous
auriez préféré qu elie semoun meurent
avant vous quand même
or il doit être dans la ferme mon avis
[Applaudissements]
les aimeriez qu'on dise quoi de vous
maintenant que vous êtes moore je pense
que je peux et je me suis plaît pas à
tout le monde donc il y aura des gens
qui vont au qui meurent ont trouvé sympa
courageux d'autres sales cons
je pense que c'est tout ça qui fait que
ce qui fait que je sais moi je suis
ailleurs la fois courageux sympa et un
sale con aussi vous l'avez trouvé
comment le discours hommage de jack lang
j'avais demandé qu'ils rentraient pas
dans le vent mais bon visiblement fin
c'est un peu débordés par des sifflets
le bon débarras de jean marie le pen
après votre mort
vous l'avez pris comment oui bon c'est
pas très sport sa part
mais bon je comprends moi aussi j'aurais
été fier sur septembre
vous êtes contents de la spéciale des
enfants de la télé qui vous a été
consacrée vendredi dernier sur tf1
c'est même presque envie de revenir chez
nous à tout est cher les obsèques
heureusement j'ai un cousin qui
travaille dans la menuiserie jeu nous a
eu des trucs cdc plus ou moins de la
cagette qui a été récupéré le corps
c'est bien foutu parce qu'on voit que du
feu puis comme toute façon c'est ça va
cramer tout ça vous laisse et du blé
derrière vaud j'ai fait des options de
carrière pour pas été vraiment sans cela
et je souhaite à chacun de s'éclater au
maximum notamment à mes enfants
évidemment je pense à eux
cependant je pense est normal vous allez
faire quoi de votre prochaine vie de
données c'est donc là vous hypothèse où
il ya le 2e but j'étais pas préparer moi
j'étais parti pour le pour une bonne
sieste mais bon puisqu'il faut y
retourner
on va retrousser les manches de la
djellaba et
et puis je sais pas pompier ça serait
pas mal c'est pas mal pompiers quand
j'étais petit je voulais faire pompiers
j'ai pas depuis le 11 septembre
[Musique]
de là
le leem hors jeu
m
tél
[Musique]
on va célébrer tout le monde s'en mêle
beaucoup de mails pour vous de jeux
d'eau quand un spectacle avec elie
semoun demande guy godefroy séguy qui
demande sa main normalement ouais je
pense que c'est un truc qu'on pourrait
refermer comme là on a je suis sur scène
à la main d'or en ce moment et dit je
sais pas vous d'elle mais on en a parlé
un moment donné c'est quelque chose qui
est possible
je pense qu'on le refera mari qui a 15
ans de vitré dans le 35
pourquoi name tue pas patrick sébastien
bon on fait avec le temps je dois dire
que je déteste patrick sébastien mais
c'est vrai que sur le moment c'était
l'histoire de la chanson casser du noir
que ça ça m'avait un peu c est mon
époque où j'étais noir est alors thibout
rené deubel jia rené simard
s'il veut parler de sa femme c'est pas
ça m'intéresse c'est pas sa famille dit
est ce que vous ne pensez pas dieudonné
que vos déclarations anti blancs et pro
ben laden ont fait progresser le vote le
pen en france il aurait fallu que je
sois présent pour pouvoir en parler moi
je pense que c'est pas moi qui ai c'est
pas mal responsable de le pen au second
tour que vous mettez le nom puis bon je
pense vraiment moi que aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit les gens regardent les choses
un petit peu différemment
je crois que l' axe du bien lax du mal
c'est une insulte au monde entier
et ce monde entier il n'a pas vraiment
sa place à la tribune en france et moi
si je peux simplement parlé un petit peu
différemment bon jean marie le pen c'est
pas un projet d'avenir de toute façon c
c'est le passé c'est vercingétorix sur
ces îles a aucun intérêt et je pense pas
que jamais il aura le pouvoir mais il
s'est bien amusés dans sa vie à dire des
bêtises et et à servir des vieux poncifs
dangereux merci donc à d'autres mails
des mails de kobe du japon de boston usa
alors là il ya un problème sur la côte
est des états unis l'émission est
diffusée trop tard donc il faut que tv5
fasse un effort
alors on a des mails de mode in en
israël de punta del este en uruguay
pareil l'émission être tarder à écouter
vous écrivez un gilbert ada tv5 voilà
beaucoup de mails pour réagir au ton et
au look de l'émission cette année
ainsi qu'aux choix des invités je les
lis tous ces gens tient compte voilà je
fais pas tout ce que vous me dites mais
je les lis tous voient comme promis
bientôt des nouvelles fraîches de notre
ami michaël blanc qui est toujours en
prison à bali et nous recevrons bientôt
une journaliste qui rentre de ben ali
voilà on passe à reporter sans
frontières plus de 100 journalistes sont
emprisonnés dans le monde
simplement pour avoir voulu s'exprimer
par exemple cents là où qui est un
birman journaliste birman qui a 66 ans
et qui est accusé d'avoir transmis des
rapports anti gouvernementaux aux médias
étrangers bien entendu alors il a pris
sept ans de prison
ce journaliste il les a exécutées dans
des conditions absolument déplorable
il devait sortir en 2001 et il n'est pas
sorti sans aucune explication voilà six
autres journalistes sont détenus en
birmanie
voilà rsf aide 100 cloud
si vous voulez aider rsf acheter l'album
yann arthus bertrand pour la liberté de
la presse je peux dire un monsieur je
vous en prie c'est notamment c'est une
des dictatures les plus sinistres du
monde qui a assigné à résidence un prix
nobel de la paix et je vous rappelle
quand même que c'est là que la société
total fina elf fait passer un gazoduc
là où on enferme des journalistes qui
ont fait travailler les enfants de force
c'est une société française pour
acheminer
du pétrole ces messieurs vous dise après
qu'ils ont des entreprises éthique et
citoyenne
merci d'avoir été avec noël mamère
m
j'accueille maintenant jean luc
mélenchon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut alors jean luc mélenchon bonsoir
votre ex julien dray était ici la
semaine dernière et il nous a raconté
comment vous l'avez quittée pour henri
emmanuelli et à quel point il a été
malheureux jusqu'à vous refusez un
cachot et l'histoire politique de
l'année c'est elle d'ailleurs comment
c'est possible un truc pareil on était
deux dans un coin hein
personne ne nous voyait ce soir ma
petite boîte de cachou jeu la pause je
fais mon petit cache ou bah oui j'ai
toujours des cachots et et alors il me
dit non non j'en veux pas bon et puis
tout d'un coup je retrouve ça dans la
presse à la télé enfin c'est une
histoire de fou il sa reynard lequel
sous un pied terrible quand vous êtes
allez faire votre nouveau monde avec
emmanueli pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
embarquer julien juge c'est votre copain
quand même venus
pourquoi vous l'avez les serrures ans
parce qu'il voulait pas c'était pas son
truc à ne voulais pas non l'amour à
trois gels avait surpris avec un autre
arrive c'est le week-end dernier donc
julien dray n'était pas à argelès dans
la salle polyvalente de la mairie fort à
l'endroit où a été portée sur les fonts
baptismaux votre nouveau courant avoué à
emmanuelli qui s'appelle le nouveau
monde et du smahrt et julien dray parce
que dès le lendemain
l'appellation nouveau monde effet
contesté par une association de
retraités qui s'appelle comme ça c'est
terrible
quand on crée un nouveau mouvement le
lendemain il ya des seniors qui hurle
c'est terrible vous avez changé de nom
vous avez pris quelques conseillers en
communication c'est une robert hue qui
arrive aux gens voilà ce qui arrive aux
gens ne compte pas de conseil en
communication qui laissent parler leur
coeur c'est pas d'ma le monde il ya des
retraités qui s'appelle nouveau monde
tant mieux pour eux vous allez rester
nouveau monde quand même
ah ouais moi je trouve ça bien j'aime çà
çà çà une dimension de de découverte
d'une belle page blanche
voilà il ya quelque chose de poétique là
dedans la politique c'est pas forcément
sinistre 1
enfin pour moi voilà lorsqu'on peut dire
juive donc c'est que l'idée de jean luc
mélenchon et d'henri emmanuelli c'est de
créer un nouveau courant sans julien au
sein du parti socialiste pour donner un
coup de barre à gauche et pour ce viré
de la direction du parti
les blairistes c'est à dire les fabius
et dominique strauss kahn et qu'il y est
mais parfois j'ai déjà tellement vraie
vie les a traités de solférino dactyle
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal je fais
attention à ce que je dis parce que le
peu que j'en ai dit la semaine dernière
ça fait toute une histoire parce que
j'ai fait des petites plaisanteries coin
rangement
oui mais la politique il ya une
dimension sérieuse et d'ailleurs vous
les médias c'est quand je dis vous je
devrais pas généraliser mais en général
c'est pas ce qui intéresse j'ai parlé
pour munich demi heure et on a retenu
dans la presse une petite phrase parce
que hein je suis parti vous savez
j'étais en train de critiquer bon il ya
deux points de vue dans le parti
socialiste un point de vue qui est
d'accompagnement de la mondialisation
libérale et de l'autre côté le point de
vue que je représente et puis à ceux qui
sont au milieu qui veulent pas tranché
alors où ils sont ni ni ni ni
et alors je suis parti dans nini et de
nini je suis passé à mini naf naf naf
9,9 parce que je me rappelle l'histoire
des trois petits cochons mais c'est pas
mal
oui mais il faut voir l'histoire que ça
fait oui mais attendez je vais vous dire
un truc bien une fonction tribunitienne
dans la politique qui existe à
l'immersion de le dire
feytiat qu'aujourd'hui les hommes
politiques souvent un discours d'experts
comptables moi je trouve ça plus rigolo
non mais sérieusement vous a plus rigolo
quand tu as un mec qui vient puis qui
fait des faits des phrases qui nous fait
un peu vibrer c'est ça la politique
n'existe plus avoir à l'assemblée
nationale et moi jusque là les choses je
parle comme je sens le la lors il ya des
moments où c'est plaisant il ya d'autres
nous c'est plus grave ya des choses qui
m'émeuvent et j'en parle dont hélas mais
mes petits camarades il sait si du
poisson lyophilisée là mais free me
bouillir laisse tomber jean luc bret
quoi allez un petit cache ou pas les
indications fait 66 morts
lorsqu'il a comme j'ai bien peur non ça
dépasse le ps ou de mai n'ont vraiment
pas que je j'ai arrêté parce que j'ai pu
mais j'ai arrêté de fumer donc tu me
décris roulement nerveux il vaut mieux
les quelques ballons jean-luc
sérieusement au congrès vous aurez avec
vous 30 40 % des militants à peu près
parce que c'est vrai que les militants
sont plus à gauche direction a requis de
gauche avec des gens de gauche données
non mais c'est vrai aussi mais c'est
vrai gentil a créé des soucis au ps les
militants sont plus à gauche que que les
patrons enfin que ceux qui dirigent
actuellement bref donc 30 40 % après
vous prenez un petit peu je pas dû
martine aubry du monde bourg et vous
faites une majorité donc vous prenez la
direction du ps imagine mal pour les
braises mais l'om c'est quand vous êtes
au pouvoir après le payant pour y
arriver
d'abord mais le pays lui éviter en train
de se droitiser donc elle sait le faire
avec votre direction boulanger c'est ça
le problème on n'essaie pas à marcher la
politique on n'est pas là à dire la
voilà j'ai amené mon petit chiffon bleu
qui est-ce qui on veut mon petit chiffon
vert à convaincre la partie politique
c'est fait pour ça et au début vous avez
des idées qui seront pas forcément
populaires parce que les idées qui vont
de soi bas c'est la vie de tous les
jours donc on change rien ça va comme ça
moi je pense qu'on peut changer les
choses quand on convint quand on
entraîne un mouvement et quand on est
quand on a le courage de ses idées tout
à l'heure là moi je vais vous faire un
reproche on a parlé de du front national
l'interdiction du front national
toujours je sais mais bien sûr j'ai six
que j'ai fait campagne avec charlie
hebdo il peut s'expliquer il faut oser
dire aux français la république et par
un régime neutre et il y en a marre de
cette comédie à la fois en huit verse
une partie de l'argent de nos impôts
pour le financer on accepte qui se
présentent à des élections et puis quand
il arrive au deuxième tour tout le monde
se met à crier au loup et et voilà des
gens comme moi qui se retrouvent à aller
voter chirac alors que j'aime mieux vous
dire que ça m'a coûté un vote théoriques
eh bien écoutez ça suffit si c'est des
ennemis de la démocratie on interdise
partie parce que la république est pas
un régime ne vous si c'est pas des
ennemis on le dit on arrête cette faune
voilà donc en fait donc fabius et
dominique strauss kahn
hollande tout ça vous dit ils ont
accepté la mondialisation libre
râle et
ils combattent pour que cette
mondialisation libérale soit la moins
mauvaise pour les gens vous la
reconnaissez ça quand même moi oui bien
sûr bien sûr en fait la vraie ligne de
fracture elle passe au sein du parti
socialiste se trouve entre ceux qui
acceptent avec la mondialisation
libérale en voulant qu'elle soit pas
trop dur pour les gens et de l'autre
côté ceux qui la refusent d'y aller j'ai
pu donner un exemple pour compenser un
peu abstrait comme ça par exemple sur le
la est-ce qu'on accepte ou pas d'ouvrir
une partie d'edf capital privé moi je
dis non rien n'est pas un maître c'est
fini terminé on arrête de privatiser
quoi que ce soit d'autre dit oui mais il
faut tenir compte de l'environnement
on est obligé de faire comme les autres
mais attention on va le faire mais en
même temps on prendra des précautions et
puis au bout de deux ans trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans vous vous êtes fait
détricoter tout le pull-over et vous
vous retrouvez avec un france télécom
qui est dans le trou alors qu'on nous
avait chanté monts et merveilles sur
l'ouverture du capital de france télécom
sur l'edf on peut pas dire en tous les
cas que le fait que edf soit
nationalisée lui interdit de mener des
djeun ventura l'étranger puisqu'il le
vrai déjà le fait déjà donc pourquoi ce
qui est incroyable c'est que c'est des
gens comme moi qui se font prendre à
partie on dit le mélenchon vous êtes en
doctrinaire vous défendez le service
public mais aux autres posent pas la
question de savoir pourquoi ils veulent
ouvrir le capital pour quoi faire
puisque ça marche et ça fonctionne c'est
eux qui sont en réalité des dogmatiques
et puis alors pour le coup c'est
vraiment des staline au libéral libéraux
vous n'êtes pas le roi de la ramener si
vous faites une critique aussitôt et
habillé pour l'hiver archaïque passéiste
tout ce qui est ce qui est moderne c'est
de libéraliser seydoux transformé en
marchandise savoir si c'est moderne en
fait ben moi je pense que c'est c'est
pour le coup c'est ce qui est plus
archaïque
c'est ce qui est plus rétro et en plus
ça marche pas si ça marchait il pourrait
nous dire on va regarder comme on y
arrive enfin c'est quand même la
californie quand même une états
développés s'est retrouvé dans le noir
pas la france 1 il étrangle l'étrangler
qui marchent pas les hôpitaux onglet qui
marchent pas enfin et pourtant les
anglais sont pas plus bêtes que d'autres
à l'époque on prenait inter on disait
vivement que ce soit des cerises et rien
ne vous en dis moi que ce soir suivent
attisé même arrière liberty sont encore
plus en retard car inter d'accord voilà
mais ça fait vendre et air inter pensez
à vous ça fait du bien d'entendre ça
parce que pendant des années on a eu
impressions se demandait si on faisait
ça fout on disait mais bon peut-être que
finalement on se trompe puisqu'ils
disent tous la même chose s est
construit et l'ampleur de la catastrophe
derrière ça fait froid dans le dos les
français se rendent pas compte ça paraît
loin à l'argentine par exemple il n'ya
pas un terroriste
il n'y a pas un communiste qui a pas un
révolutionnaire à l'horizon le pays
s'est fracassée faut savoir l'argentine
c'est un pays développé
c'est un pays qui était du niveau de
l'italie bien sûr et qui est par terre
les gens les gens ne savent plus quoi
faire on fabrique des billets en
écrivant dessus pour échanger les ce qui
s'est passé en argentine récemment il ya
un camion qui transportait des bleus qui
a eu un accident le camion s'est
renversé et les gens sont venus avec des
couteaux alors que les argentins sommes
un peuple assez développée quand vous
regardez savage
ils sont arrivés avec des couteaux et
ils ont découpé les boeufs au bord de la
route pour pouvoir manger voilà où ils
en sont en argentine en grâce de la
région à cause de l'effet mais bien
alors quand vous avez lancé un mouvement
qui s'appelle nouveau monde
on va faire une interview nouveau monde
[Musique]
alors jean luc mélenchon est ce que dans
le nouveau monde des enfants de 13 ans
iront en prison
non et on créera plus de place d'écoles
que de places en prison ça c'est clair
est ce que dans le nouveau monde martine
aubry sera la première présidente de la
république à pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
je faisais des élections défaisant la
république au suffrage universel
indirect comme ça ça a l'air sympa hein
en réalité sa fausse tout cela
personnalise à mort la politique c'est
plus médiatique et luc wasquehal plus de
thunes et cela semble le mieux la télé
ça finit comme ça hein ça finit comme ça
des fois il ya des exceptions parce que
regarder par exemple le brésil c'est le
gars de gauche qui va être un loup lac
est un ouvrier lula il a dû s'y
reprendre à quatre fois mais alors les
deux autres fois il y avait vraiment de
quoi se couper les mains est la télé
inventé un candidat trois mois avant et
c'est comme ça que l'on retrouvait qu'un
crétin comme color 1 1 qu'il a fallu
fiche dehors six mois après tellement
ils étaient voyous et voleurs comme oui
c'est comme ça que berlusconi est devenu
président en italie quoi
et bien non mais ce qui est terrible
c'est que votre copain non votre copain
la nouvelle-ville huilée pour l'élection
du président de la république au
suffrage universel direct
vous n'êtes pas d'accord moi je serais
déjà peine on attend on ne sert à rien
de s'en convainc st
est ce que dans le nouveau monde
julien dray aura le droit d'entrée oui
et même de manger des cachous sans
grossir d'ailleurs est ce que dans le
nouveau monde on aura le droit de se
pacser à trois ou à quatre petits spots
de publicité la première loi déposé
devant le parlement
première fois qu'on a déposé une loi
pour le pacs avancé mois un sénat a été
si ce n est pas beaucoup de héros à
l'épaule est bon depuis c'est devenu un
peu plus pop et l'a34 non je ne pense
pas que c'est une bonne pourquoi c'est
vrai pourquoi mais je dis ça dépend pour
quoi faire
bah ouais bof non mais attends je peux
donner un exemple sérieuse et de
nombreux trucs sérieux
alors pourquoi faire
c'est bien ce que je dis ça dépend si
ces voix au début je voulais que
n'importe qui puisse se pacser je
n'étais pas dans l'idée seulement les
couples à qui on y est tout droit en
l'occurrence les couples homosexuels
vous étiez pour le passage des frères
des soeurs de voler on m'a dit un ton
truc c'est une histoire de fou c'est un
fait ça on va plus s'y retrouver
il y en a qui m'ont dit tu vas favoriser
l'inceste on manie donc je me suis dit
le mieux est l'ennemi du bien prenons
déjà puisque tout le monde est d'accord
pour faire le pacs on prend déjà ça et
on verra après est ce que dans le
nouveau monde la lune sera blonde la
terre sera rondeurs afférentes comme
dans la chanteuse elle est super la
shoah est ce que dans le nouveau monde y
aura toujours cette émission là oui et
puis en plus je serai plus souvent
invités
m
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
voici luc plamondon
[Musique]
sami
bien alors on va commencer par la
question
[Musique]
et cette semaine et cette semaine la
question est trop con pour que je la
pose moi même donc c'est toi qui est
bien là posé pour bien poser la question
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir alors luc plamandon pourquoi
toujours lunettes noires parce que ce
voyage
merci quand même pourquoi parce qu'un
auteur c'est un voyage un moi j'écris je
regarde les gens vivre j'écris en vie
sans qu'il le sache
c'est pour ça qu'ils se reconnaissent
dans mes chansons bravo les flamands
dont didier
[Musique]
j'aurais voulu les toits 6
moi
avant
vous voulez
là
je t'aime
je
[Musique]
jamais
l'autre
d'imagés
[Musique]
quand
oh
[Musique]
c'est en question de pvd
m
[Musique]
oh
d'or
et
oui
e
ce temps
[Musique]
c'est qu'elle même
dans ces deux consoles
le venu le temps des 4
et je lève
[Musique]
du moins
choisir
[Applaudissements]
luc plamondon
[Musique]
et voilà si entre temps la police
alors
notamment dans 500 chansons ce qui fait
une chanson tous les quinze jours deux
lignes par jour et pas de ligne de
lignes écrites et mises bout à bout ça
fait vingt-quatre heures deux chansons
c'est absolument incroyable et la
dernière en date c'est celle là
c'est une chanson extraite de votre
nouvelle comédie musicale donc cindy qui
est jusqu'au 29 décembre au palais des
congrès porte maillot avec l'âme
franck sherbourne karine du loft parce
qu'aujourd'hui karine du l'ofs
carine star academy c'est la crise moi
honnêtement je m'en branle
hu a extrait de cindy la nouvelle
comédie musicale de luc plamondon
musique de moossou mara jusqu'au 29
décembre au palais des congrès porte
maillot avec l'âme
franck cherbourg mme karine de star
académie acia et des dépôts éthique
lover man show et genève
[Applaudissements]
notre fils est roi
et du coup je le sais
- parmi tout seul
[Applaudissements]
je l'aimerai
on s'est très
beaucoup
voilà donc c'est l'histoire de
cendrillon france plongée dans le monde
moderne ce que le mollah dieudonné suis
toute l'histoire la de plamondon ça va
oui je ne sais pas en fait mais alors
lui plamondon donc c'est l'histoire de
cendrillon transposer dans le monde
moderne et c'est peut-être là un
problème car ce kit est moderne du temps
de starmania n'était plus aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui les gens ils
ont pas envie de voir un conte de fées
qui se passe dans un pavillon qui se
passe dans des cafétérias et des choses
comme ça non les 15 25 ans ensemble est
notre public cible et il m'a dit on
adore ça parce que c'est moderne parce
que c'est notre vie parce que c'est pas
quelque chose qui parle d'un e siècle ou
d'un autre monde ça parle de nous ça
parle du monde dans lequel on vit
et moi j'ai eu envie cette fois ci
justement pour sortir de notre dame de
paris bon j'ai vécu au xvème siècle
pendant cinq ans pratiquement donc
j'avais envie de revenir en 2002 qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec le musicien
compositeur des mélodies de notre dame
de paris
coach et vous irez écouter les maladies
qu'il a fait pour le petit prince
comment gérer des nouvelles ah bon vous
pouvez sont pas bien consciente fait des
mélodies somptueuses pour notre réseau
mais et des mélodies qu'il avait dans
ses tiroirs la plupart depuis depuis 10
15 ans que j'ai récolté après il en a
fait d'autres
le mariage magique entre un auteur et
compositeur s'est pas forcément pour la
vie c'est sur un sujet ça marche les
musiques de coacher en était
merveilleuse pour notre dame de paris
alors c'est la guerre avec coach en qui
vous accuse de lui avoir accordé il a
dit qu'il voulut avait volé notre dame
de paris
pourquoi parce que vous parliez pas
assez de lui dans les interviews c'est
ça qui veut dire moi je réponds aux
questions dans les interviews
au début on parlait pas de lui et
maintenant on parle de lui et si on
parlait pas de lui avant le programme de
paris c'est pas ma faute mais c'est
quand même grâce à moi qu'on parle de
lui maintenant non c'est un peu comme ça
entre déjà
[Musique]
alors le premier single qui s'appelait
un monde à nous c'est pas très très bien
vendu faut le dire un lui qu'il faut
être fou être honnête
trois cent mille copies c'est malien bon
évidemment quand on a fait des ventes de
millions on voudrait qu'on vend toujours
des millions du jour au lendemain mais
non mais c'est vrai qu'au même stade
l'album s'est vendu à 200 mille
exemplaires pour cindy way et au même
stade
notre âme était à 400 milles quoi si
vous voulez c'est à double tranchant de
sortir un disque avant parce qu'on est
obligés de faire des chansons
enregistrées dans des formats pour la
radio 1
on dévoile pas forcément l'oeuvre on
raconte pas forcément l'histoire
cela a en angleterre et aux états unis
vont dans les grands pays de comédie
musicale
les gens achètent le double là il écoute
l'histoire sur disque les gens non mais
c'est vrai il faut dire la vérité on
peut se le dire la ici des gens sur un
peu déçu quoi c'est à dire c'est pas le
triomphe de notre dame de paris
l'âme les gens disent pourquoi est-ce
qu'il a choisi l'âme l'a même trouvé les
chansons guimauve un moment elle a voulu
partir qu'elle avait un contrat jusqu'en
2003 donc c'est vrai on peut le dire
quoi c'est pas c'est pas le succès de
notre dame mais des gens qui vient de
voir la mla trouve merveilleuse parce
que ils s'attendent à ce qu'ils fassent
beaucoup de ce gros fait rentrer la
chose avec une sincérité naturel
extraordinaire tout le monde sorte qu'on
qui paraît il ya des rôles secondaires
très fort qu'ils font vraiment des
triomphes et d'être confiants vous moi
j'aime ce que j'ai écrit et si le public
aime ce que j'ai écrit je me fous de ce
que disaient les journaux
allez les jours nous faut dire ils n'ont
pas été très sain par le parisien
scénario confus décor inexistant le
critique de parisiens d'abord il n'était
pas invité le premier soir n'est la
presse était invitée à partir du transit
n'a pas respecté le deal il est entré de
force dans la salle il s'est assis sur
le rebord de la scène avec son
ordinateur avec le show qui étaient là
ils regardent
il a tapé c'est une critique sans même
voir le show assis sur la scène on
aurait pu lui prendre son ordinateur il
lui foutent sur la gueule
finalement il est essentiel mais vous
parce qu'on sait jamais vous projet
était sorti de la salle mais ça c'est
pas ne sait pas faire ça s'appelle pas
faire de la critique de ce pays
ça ça s'appelle faire de la kabbale donc
ouest-france dit les stars sont
transparents murray décevant françois 10
heures là ça vous concerne
particulièrement à luc plamondon les
textes frisent souvent le niveau zéro
est prête à rire
on n'a pas de mots c'est pas de ma faute
l'indicé est pour lui parce que là lundi
soir donc il ya eu la première bourre et
de pippo vous avez vraiment la terre
entière il y avait même céline dion et
son nez j'étais pas là je défendrai
n'était pas là et pas la terre entière
et je viendrai la salle s'est levée
paraît-il pour applaudir en fin de
spectacle
malgré donc toutes ces mauvaises
critiques et puis ces rumeurs un peu
négatif qui courent sur le spectacle en
ce moment à paris
est ce que vous croyez qu'ils se sont
levés à la fin du spectacle parce qu'ils
avaient bien aimée ou parce qu'ils sont
hypocrites
je pense qu'elle est
j'avais bien aimé se sont enlevées et on
criait et ils étaient très nombreux mais
les hypocrites se sont levés pour ne pas
rester assis peut-être mais je
tout le monde était debout tout là et on
sait très bien que dans ces salles il ya
souvent des gens qui viennent pour
détester au départ bien sûr et d'autres
qui viennent pour aimer ceux qui sont
venus pour rim et je crois n'ont pas été
déçus alors le taux de remplissage est
de combien en ce moment on joue dans la
salle du palais d'écran de la version
1800 places qui est la salle la version
pour l'idéal pour faire une tournée
musicale et on doit faire une moyenne de
400 personnes par soir sur une salle qui
peut quand même accueillir 3700
personnes peut agrandir à 3 mais c'est
en personne pour notre dame on a agrandi
1 3 minutes mais ça n'arrive pas tous
les jours
est ce que charles talar le producteur
est ce que charles va rentrer dans son
pognon parce que c'est ça finalement la
zac la ville en eau perez a quand même
mis 7 millions cinq cent mille euros a
quand même je suis beaucoup plus
économique il faut dire sur cette oeuvre
une comédie musicale ça se rentabilise à
très long terme est et on fera des
grandes surprises
moi ce qui se passe ça me rappelle ce
avec quoi ça me rappelle le servage
cabale dont on est victime ça me
rappelle cynégétique on dit c'est une
opérette carton qui devra le temps le
château de cartes comme ça et 25 à 25
ans après on joue encore far magna et
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui avait entendu
quand on chante les chansons de
starmania il échange d'idées connaissent
et survécu à toutes les attentions
c'est ça qui me donne le courage de
servir en même temps mais je passais
autre crise si vous êtes comme tout le
monde j'ai vu me fais plein de bible moi
le premier lui tout le monde à lily
passion ça pas été avec depardieu et
barbara ça peut être un triomphe la
jetterait pas pour grand-chose dioxyde
de carbone lorraine dioxyde de carbone
c'était très punk quitterai mon époque
très marginale
non mais voilà vous avez fait des trucs
énormes contrer très bien marché on
entendu tout à l'heure un bout de vos
500 chansons vous avez fait des trucs
comme la légende de jimmy sans délai
romantique
voilà enfin je veux dire que les
créateurs ont soit vous vient ce
françois cinéaste ou qu'on soit auteur
de comédies musicales ont déjà été des
flops à tour de rôle
je suis d'accord c'est dans on le saura
dans trois mois dans la lah mois dans un
an on saura comment ça marche le petit
prince
pour le moment il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
de vente non plus encore le disque s'est
pas vendu et les places nous se sont
beaucoup moins en vue que les nôtres
mais peut-être que
la presse si la presse les privilégient
peut-être que ça leur donnerait un
avantage sur nous moi je prône un moment
il ya que deux critiques qui sont parus
de chaque côté les deux mains vides mais
les deux les deux farouchement contre
nous mais farouchement tôt dans le
parisien soutien des sponsors du petit
prince
alors ça vous est déjà tout de suite
sérieusement pour finir là-dessus vous
prenez pas qu'il y avait trop de
comédies musicales qu'à un moment les
gens ont l'impression que après le
succès de quelques unes maintenant ça
devient effectivement de l'industrie du
marketing
je crois pas je pense que les gens qui
sait que les trois comédies musicales
décathlon marché c'est de starmania
notre dame roméo juliette et les dix
commandements ont créé un vrai public
qui existe maintenant et qui a envie
d'en voir d'autres ont moins une par
année
merci lui plan dont vous avez vu comment
elle a rangé vos cachot jean-luc elle
est bien cette fille
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant fred du groupe
aston villa
bompas comme bilal on vous êtes le
leader du groupe un groupe dont
libération alors la ceni françois anil
parisien ces libérations disait le 27
septembre dernier
aston villa continue de s'affirmer en
somme comme le meilleur groupe français
en exercice
mine de rien et des 96 libération
écrivez c'est le groupe dont on va
parler voilà donc vous on peut pas dire
entre les caves où il a presque honte
rejoint tout va bien donc vous sortez
aujourd'hui votre quatrième album c'est
le troisième en studio il s'appelle
strange est le premier single c'est le
chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
aucune
non
[Musique]
le chien aston villa alors une
explication à ce type que je trouve
assez bonne l'individu moyen est pris
entre ses problèmes de cul et de qi il
perds un peu les pédales et il se
demande si finalement il n'est pas juste
le meilleur ami de son chien sur sa
formidable club comme phrase il ya une
autre chanson intéressante c'est la
dernière d'ailleurs dans votre album
savez le slow food vous avez invité jean
louis aubert alain bashung d'asie les
robins des bois jean pierre coffe pour
lire le menu de du grand cuisinier
gagnaire c'est contre la mondialisation
contre l'uniformisation de la de la
bouffe c'est bizarre de trouver ce genre
de trucs dans votre disque non c'est une
réponse aussi à des gens qui peuvent
dire que l'exception culturelle
française n'a pas lieu d'être s'est il
ya un acte militant c'est vrai c'est une
façon de mettre en avant la culture
française la bonne bouffe la gastronomie
et puis représentés par des gens qui
représentent cette culture française des
auteurs des chanteurs des écrivains et à
jacques lanzmann aussi alors donc vous
êtes en tournée dans toute la france est
beaucoup de scènes en fait partie de ces
groupes qui vont au contact du public
dont louise attaque a été vraiment
l'exemple le plus signifiant je dirais
alors vous appelez aston villa à cause
du club anglais le foot
aston villa votre nom vous a aidé à vous
faire connaître aston villa non mais
c'est vrai que c'était ça faisait ça
sonne et internationales saverne crsr
anglo saxons ashton méditerranéen villa
voilà ça marche très bien
chalon qui en jette ouais ouais on est
on là dedans
ils adorent ce moment ça vous a aidé à
vous faire connaître il ya un truc qui
vous aviez aussi à vous faire connaître
c'est les victoires delà de la musique
en 2001 va regarder magnéto serge
gagnant son aston villa
[Musique]
alors la coutume veut que dans cette
circonstance en formule des
remerciements
nous n'allons pas faillir la tradition
mais j'aimerais laisser le soin des
remerciements à mes petits camarades et
moi avec on répond j'aimerais dire
quelques mots à propos de ce qu on ne
remercie pas alors nous remercions pas
la maison de disques bmg chez qui nous
avons sorti notre premier album il ya
quelques années et je pense en
particulier au pdg de l'époque monsieur
hervé lasseigne qui par son entêtement
et son incompétence a bien failli mettre
un terme à la carrière de notre groupe
alors si je parle de d'hervé la série
aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement parce
que je suis rancunier c'est plus pour
attirer votre attention sur danger qu'il
y a parachuté à la tête des maisons de
10 des gens qui ne connaissent
absolument rien à ce métier mais qui
sous prétexte qu'ils ont obtenu de bons
résultats à la tête d'une firme de
chaussettes ou 2 couches culottes sont
considérées aptes à diriger de maisons
de disques alors l'individu auquel je
faisais allusion avant de diriger avant
d'être pdg chez bmg
il arrivait du yaourt où il était
paraît-il très performant et donc il lui
a paru naturel de vendre des disques
comme il avait vendu du yaourt par
paquet de six par paquets de douze têtes
de gondoles et surtout on jette quand la
date est passée
alors j'aimerais lui dire ce soir s'ils
nous écoute que contrairement à
un du yaourt un artiste un groupe n'est
pas une matière inerte un groupe ça peut
se remettre en question ça peut
travailler ça peut progresser et ça peut
finir par fonctionner même après avoir
eu des débuts un peu laborieux mais ça
pour savoir il fallait connaître ce
métier il fallait être en contact avec
les artistes là ce n est pas juste
rester dans son bureau à consulter les
hits parade en musique info hebdo
alors nous on n'est pas des utopistes le
show business on sait ce que c'est on
sait très bien qu'une maison de disque
peut pas faire éternellement du
développement sur un artiste il
fonctionne pas mais la politique qui
consiste à virer tout le monde au bout
d'un an parce qu'un album n'est pas
disque d'or ça c'est peut-être bon pour
la danse de l'été pour les lofteurs ou
pour ceux qui ont eu leur bac musique
dans une académie de stars mais pour les
autres pour les jours pour ceux qui ne
sont pas de la musique pour les autres
ceux qui ne sont pas de la musique corps
opportunisme et par passion ça vaut
peut-être la peine dès lors les simples
temps et voir ce qu'ils peuvent donner
sur le long terme
pour bercy
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
ça avance beaucoup de vent mais ce n'est
pas née après donc quand vous avez eu le
prix de la découverte de l'année
bmj a ressorti le dit ce qu'ils
voulaient pas promouvoir à l'époque avec
un sticker inclus et c'est donc en plus
ils ont aucun scrupule bien vous avez
déclaré dans un magazine qui s'appelle
fhm en octobre il faut être vigilant et
résister à la daube qu'on nous balance
est-ce que vous pensez que cindy c'est
de la daube oui oui je vois là je
préfère être franc je n'accroche pas du
tout avec cindy autant j'ai accroché
avec starmania l'époque
non non mais c'est une grave et donne
pas envie d'y aller quand je vois des
extrêmes et c'est pas ça remet pas en
question tous les gens qui sont derrière
et peut-être l'écriture et ce qui a été
écrit avant tu vois c'est juste
peut-être ponctuelles c'est peut-être à
ce moment là je mets ça me touche moi
mais les choses qu'on ne sait quelle
chance ça se juge sur scène c'est ccc
déballer ses cd numéro c'est c'est un
spectacle c'est pas un truc pour être
écouté sur dix qui est surtout pas pour
être vu en extraire la télévision c'est
un tout c'est c'est du spectacle
totalement et chacun ses goûts mais tu
as parfaitement à droite de fait comme
si on me demandait si j'aime tant
dernier ce que je répondrais je les pré
écoute et mais bon mais je vais
l'écouter il est bien
c'est qu'on termine en écoutant une
chanson écrite par michel rivard une
façon de beau dommage qui est la seule
chanson que luc plamondon aurait aimé
écrire c'est une chanson quelques dents
chez assez jaloux que je trouve très
bien oui
take part en alaska
[Musique]
un femme
ennuyant
semblant d'être assis
gagner sa vie dans un cercle
11 les pommes
[Musique]
ça
et
est ce que c'est
je
[Musique]
en ce sens
terry ray
est ce que pour finir luc plamondon est
ce que finalement vous n'avez pas envie
de laisser tomber toutes ces grandes
machineries ses grues sur scène c'est un
investissement de plusieurs millions
d'euros et avec le talent que vous avez
vous réfugier dans une cabane au canada
écrire des belles chansons comme celle
là comme toutes celles que vous avez
écrite ce bourdonnement ce que je vais
faire les deux prochaines années mais
pas à pas ce que je vais furent des
grandes machineries mois sans je voulais
faire un petit spectacle de cendrillon
mais on a dit que c'est un non sujet
populaire donc j'ai dit ok allons-y
on verra si c'est un grand sujet
populaire
on verra en tous les cas juger sur pièce
allez-y c'est au palais des congrès
jusqu'au 29 décembre
merci fred narcy aston villa et
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
ce qui le fait dans la nuit le programme
arte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
facile
bonsoir moi donc basile boli vous êtes
ancien international français vous
dirigez aujourd'hui une société de
marketing sportif et vous publiez avec
un journaliste de rfi qui s'appelle pape
touré chez anne carrière un livre qui
s'appelle les lions de la terenga
c'est-à-dire un livre consacré à
l'équipe nationale du sénégal
ça veut dire quoi teranga la teranga ces
séances en wolof
c'est le bienvenu c'est à l'afrique on a
l'habitude de recevoir les gens dans des
situations un peu fraternelle donc la
teranga c'est l'hospitalité en fait
voilà alors le 31 mai 2002 match
d'ouverture de la coupe du monde les
bleus contre le sénégal
alors les bleus finalement et je tousse
dans des clubs étrangers sauf le boeuf
dugarry et et cissé et les sénégalais il
est venu tout ça en championnat 3 donc
là c'est vrai qu'à un paradoxe dans ce
match comme ça pour tout le monde s'est
jouée d'avancé ce match et la surprise
générale le sénégal gagne 1 0 mais c'est
la loi du sport parce que
sur le papier la france pourrait gagner
sur dix matches neuf fois et là il s'est
trouvé que bon les françaises avaient
peut-être moins faim et avait peut-être
une cohésion qui manquait et les
sénégalais en ont profité voilà et ça
fait qu' une petite équipe nationale qui
participe pour la première fois au face
au nahd la coupe du monde rencontre le
champion du monde le championne d'europe
et il gagne deux places est
extraordinaire c'est extraordinaire la
l'épopée commencer elle durera jusqu'aux
quarts de finale
l étable dit par tout le monde d'abord
par les sénégalais bien sûr parler par
les africains par tout le continent
africain mais aussi par les français
c'est vrai qu'à un moment les français
ont reporté leur soutien assez rapide
assez rapidement ce qui ce qui est
normal parce que bon le sénégal est un
francophile sait plus on se retrouve
tout de suite en c'est vraiment le
peuple frère aurait alors basile boli
est ce que cette victoire du sénégal sur
la france donc dès le premier match
venge l'absence de la france aux
obsèques du président senghor
pas spécialement c'est que senghor a été
pour les africains le garant de la
culture française en afrique et le fait
que singer soit mort en normandie et qui
retourne en france et que c'est mal
perçus par les
par les politiciens français moi ça au
moins ça m'a choqué parce que étant
français d'origine ivoirienne
je me dis si jamais il m'arrive un truc
que je meurs a duré tout le monde oublie
quoi alors basile boli va vous parler du
sénégal dans votre bouquin mais en fait
vous êtes ivoirien
bien sûr gênés en côte d'ivoire était à
abidjan à l'époque d'houphouët boigny
autres grands leaders africains s'il en
est votre père était militaire est alors
j'aurai qu'on parle un petit peu de
cette crise ivoirienne parce que tout le
monde en parle c'est le cas de le dire
tir au début on a pris ça a vu d'ici on
a pris ça un petit peu comme une
rébellion de quelques militaires dans le
nord du pays ça semblait pas très grave
en fait au départ et puis ce qui
semblait être une mutinerie dans
quelques villes du nord maintenant il ya
un véritable déferlement militaire du
nord vers le sud et s'il n'y avait pas
l'armée française qui faisait tampon à
yamassoukro finalement on se demande si
abidjan ne serait pas occupé par les
mutins d'une certaine façon vous savez
en côte d'ivoire la côte d'ivoire est un
pays de paix d'abord les ivoiriens ne
sont pas des méchants
premièrement deuxièmement c'est pas
c'est vrai qu'elle est ancion ethniques
et les tensions entre le nord et le sud
ce qui est normal mais pourquoi non
justement vous dit ce qui est normal est
ce qu'il ya une différence ethnique ou
religieux sentent ethnies en côte
d'ivoire une entre le nord et le sud est
ce qu'un livre à 7 milliards si si si la
tension ethnique existe le entre le nord
et le sud c'est-à-dire le nord musulman
et le sud là car voilà le sud chrétien
animiste et le nord mais mais prenez pas
ça comme ça ça se passe que moi j'ai les
musulmans dans ma famille mon père était
musulman
donc je veux dire que on est on est on a
été dans un pays où l'intégration
l'exemple de l'intégration d'afrique
c'est en côte d'ivoire parce que avoir
un seul pays où il ya deux millions de
sénégalais trois millions de burkinabè
ça n'existe pas en europe à cannes a
fixé ce avait déconnecté éduqué dans
dents
pour savoir donner la main et ce qui se
passe en côte d'ivoire aujourd'hui c'est
pas le fait d'une ethnie à une autre
ethnie c'est pas un groupe de dub
anglais qui attaquent dbtc des ethnies
entre parenthèses c'est des militaires
qui sont contre le pouvoir de monsieur
gbagbo
mais voilà c'est pas je veux dire c'est
donc c'est valable
voilà il est énoncé ses instants et le
groupe de militaires d'acquis qu'ils
étaient avec l'ancien général est gay
voilà on est d'accord dans l'axé mais ni
ethniques ni religieux
si je dis pas qu'il n'y a pas de tension
bien il ya une tension ethnique fonction
économique parce que tout part de là
est-ce qu'on est parti pour une guerre
civile de longue durée
ben j'espère pas parce que j'ai encore
de la famille là-bas j'ai des amis et je
pense que il faut pas je pense que c'est
un problème qui doit être résolu par des
africains eux mêmes
et puis si on a besoin disons de la
france logistiquement ben voila quoi je
pense que on a on a des des gens
capables de se réunir l'afrique des gens
sensés pour pouvoir résoudre de ce
problème
merci d'être venu témoigner d'asile
[Musique]
a sion avec claude touré
le plongeur
m
la galère
on passe au blind test ce soir en blind
test spécial tube de tout le monde en
parle
dédié à louis et amis non aux platines
j'appelle moi j'avais les porter
il est même
[Musique]
et pour jouer avec nous j'appelle dan
bolender et la magie noire
[Applaudissements]
santelli scudamore
je vous avoue ensuite essayé cette
semaine paris s'est très très bien passé
on m'a dit attention le blind test va
commencer je veux l'interprète didier
red deer et attention on a une
chorégraphie super au pm on a un truc
avec arnaud regarde le numéro commun il
me semble qu'ils sont qui gagne
maintenant tu parles
attention fille tu veux l'interprète
[Musique]
dangereuse
[Applaudissements]
les oiseaux sont des confidents mais
quand je suis contre mais dont ils me
comprennent tous ensemble
l'interprète du son le souffle d'un mémo
on aime les animaux ils sont moins
n'en revient pas d'avoir gagné 1,8
fernandel absolument on ne souffle pas
attention
ça fait un point partout
attention film
[Musique]
en voyage ou au cinéma vous avez vu
l'himalaya l'acropole
bien bien bien bien attention philippe
[Musique]
ce terme
souffert
[Applaudissements]
le monde ne nous a pas souri à gags ya
un souffle
j'ai simplement vu des filles qui
n'étaient pas épilée sous les bras quand
elle levait les bras
mais attention pas de soufflage sinon je
obligé de faire évacuer la sarb ça mais
ça s'est toujours très désagréable s'est
déjà vu donc ça fait 3 points pour vous
mes amis
[Applaudissements]
hollande est un petit mètre un soufflage
forcément attention philippe
[Musique]
6 3
vivifier tous absolument attention film
m
[Applaudissements]
cependant là non il ya eu soufflage les
entendu si bref la danse lagon
sa soeur
regardez là bas qu'ici d'alba l'inter
qui avait toujours dans les tubes de
tout le monde en parle
mais en vélo herbert léonard
chassons écrite par julien lepers
mesdames et messieurs pour le plaisir
que vous avez reconnu à la première note
dan bolender c'est énorme yapi tobo jean
verreault ouais donc ça fait quatre
points pour vous quand même toujours et
deux points pour eux attention philippa
m
[Musique]
souffle
reus ont fait rage je ne veux pas
augmenter le poids je ne peux pas
compter le poids
on peut dire que basile boli et de la
feuille parce qu'il a entendu quelqu'un
qui disait et mylène c'est sûr par obama
la connaissez d'accord attention je ne
veux pas de soufflage philippe
[Applaudissements]
et ça fait 5 points pour vous toujours 2
pour vous mais l'on sent vraiment les
gars qu'est ce que c'est ce nouveau
monde
ouais attention philippe
[Musique]
fb
monde
à
c'est avec gwen stefani mais c'est un
featuring gwen stefani donc c'est m
donc vous avez gagné encore une fois dan
bolender ça fait 3 ben c'est déjà pas
mal c'est déjà pas mal il reste encore
deux petites peut-être vous allez
pouvoir égaliser
philippe
[Musique]
non
ouais le
le chanteur s'est passé
oui
[Applaudissements]
cela
je veux non nous arrêter attention
[Musique]
attention donc maintenant nous allons
passer aux super banco l'équipe qui
trouvera le super banco de toute façon
aura gagné la partie oui c'est moche
mais mentir parce que la vie est injuste
suit le mouvement
[Musique]
une bible on
non
je donnais présidence et jean arnaud
gidoin d'y remporter ce bundle mairie
l'émission qui vous
guillaume ii
jean-paul en jeu la santé
avec guillaume depardieu
la bo mater la néo de pronoms
avec ma joue
encore à l'événement
de la paix
michel leblanc la chasse à l'homme
la mort de m
c'est publié je vaux
je me donne
me ghedini
avec lui
emilie banane
ce social à 14 jeunes à parler dans le
chacun
je ne
m
or cellulaire
en janvier
100 millions de
demandeur et romano boussouma va avec
dernier
c'est au palais des congrès
l'album s'appelle j'ai plus appris en
2002 et le site
je les mange frais
aston villa
c'est suite à venir
le
dans le cas des sacrements malaise
social de paris vas-y
mais bien
et face noire
c'est un gars
hier pour la liberté
soufflant dans cette émission va
merci par là
[Musique]
g
mais
[Musique]
il
e
[Musique]
non
play